I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Hello! Get out your snorkels.
I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Hello! Get out your snorkels.|||我是珍娜·费舍尔，我是安吉拉·金西。我们一起出演过《办公室》，而且我们是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你制作了终极《办公室》重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有身临其境的两个人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女士们。大家好！快拿出你们的呼吸管吧。
Uh, I am so excited. Today, I loved this episode in the rewatch. It was so fun and we have so many fun people who are going to share memories from this episode. I say let's get into it. I'm excited. Well, before we get started, we have some morning announcements. Did you have morning announcements in school?
Uh, I am so excited. Today, I loved this episode in the rewatch. It was so fun and we have so many fun people who are going to share memories from this episode. I say let's get into it. I'm excited. Well, before we get started, we have some morning announcements. Did you have morning announcements in school?|||呃，我太兴奋了。今天，我在重温时特别喜欢这一集。它太有趣了，而且我们有很多有趣的人来分享这一集的记忆。我说我们开始吧。我很兴奋。好吧，在我们开始之前，有一些早间通知。你们上学时有早间通知吗？
Like, did a person come on the intercom and give you morning announcements? Yes. Me too. Me too. But they still do it. I think they're still morning announcements. We had this thing when I was a senior in high school where the seniors got to take over the morning announcements for a week.
Like, did a person come on the intercom and give you morning announcements? Yes. Me too. Me too. But they still do it. I think they're still morning announcements. We had this thing when I was a senior in high school where the seniors got to take over the morning announcements for a week.|||比如说，会有人通过对讲机广播早间通知吗？有。我也是。我也是。但他们现在还在这样做。我想现在应该还有早间通知。我上高三的时候有这么个规定：高三学生可以接管早间通知一周。
I know. It was like a big, fun thing. All right. Well, I'm going to do my best at a morning announcement. This is really exciting. We now have signed copies of our book, The Office BFFs, available for pre-order. They are online right now at the following retailers, Barnes & Noble, Books A Million, BJ's Wholesalers, and Premier Collectibles, and you can support independent bookstores
I know. It was like a big, fun thing. All right. Well, I'm going to do my best at a morning announcement. This is really exciting. We now have signed copies of our book, The Office BFFs, available for pre-order. They are online right now at the following retailers, Barnes & Noble, Books A Million, BJ's Wholesalers, and Premier Collectibles, and you can support independent bookstores|||我知道。这就像是一件非常有趣的大事。好吧。嗯，我会尽力播报一条早间通知。这真的让人很兴奋。我们现在有签名的书籍《办公室好闺蜜》（The Office BFFs）可供预订了。它们现在已经在以下零售商的网站上线了：Barnes & Noble、Books A Million、BJ's Wholesalers 以及 Premier Collectibles，你也可以支持独立书店，
by purchasing a signed copy at Strand Bookstore. You guys, Jenna and I signed thousands of copies of books, boxes and boxes of these sheets of paper that were pages from our book that they bind into the book. Yes. And I mean, our families, I feel like they were like, what are you, are you signing more? Okay. Are you signing more? What are you doing?
by purchasing a signed copy at Strand Bookstore. You guys, Jenna and I signed thousands of copies of books, boxes and boxes of these sheets of paper that were pages from our book that they bind into the book. Yes. And I mean, our families, I feel like they were like, what are you, are you signing more? Okay. Are you signing more? What are you doing?|||通过在斯特兰德书店（Strand Bookstore）购买签名版来支持他们。伙计们，珍娜和我签了数千本书，一箱又一箱的纸，这些纸都是书里的内页，之后会被装订进书中。是的。而且我的意思是，我们的家人，我感觉他们就像是在说：“你们在干嘛，又在签名吗？好吧。你们还在签名吗？你们到底在做什么？”
Oh, you're signing more? Like that was like the narrative for weeks. I set up a little TV tray by our TV in our family room. And when we would watch a movie, I would just, all you would hear in the background was a Sharpie going, it took me two months to sign all of these. Yeah. This was a big project. Yeah.
Oh, you're signing more? Like that was like the narrative for weeks. I set up a little TV tray by our TV in our family room. And when we would watch a movie, I would just, all you would hear in the background was a Sharpie going, it took me two months to sign all of these. Yeah. This was a big project. Yeah.|||“哦，你们还在签？”连续好几个星期，这话简直成了家常便饭。我在家庭活动室的电视旁支了一个小电视托盘。每当我们要看电影时，我就会——你能在背景音里听到的只有马克笔发出的沙沙声，我花了两个月才把这些全签完。是的。这是一个大工程。是的。
But they're out there. They are available. You can find a link on our OfficeLadies.com website. We're going to put it up on our socials. And you can also find it at hc.com slash office bffs. We signed them with love, you guys. We did. We signed them with love.
But they're out there. They are available. You can find a link on our OfficeLadies.com website. We're going to put it up on our socials. And you can also find it at hc.com slash office bffs. We signed them with love, you guys. We did. We signed them with love.|||但它们现在已经发行了。它们已经可以买到了。你可以在我们的网站 OfficeLadies.com 上找到链接。我们也会把它发到我们的社交媒体上。你还可以在 hc.com/office-bffs 上找到它。伙计们，我们是用心签名的。真的。我们是用爱签名的。
Okay. Morning announcements are done. Let's get in to this episode. Today we are breaking down Koi Pond. It is season six, episode eight written by Warren Lieberstein and Halstead Sullivan and directed by Reggie Hudlin. Here is your summary. It's very simple.
Okay. Morning announcements are done. Let's get in to this episode. Today we are breaking down Koi Pond. It is season six, episode eight written by Warren Lieberstein and Halstead Sullivan and directed by Reggie Hudlin. Here is your summary. It's very simple.|||好了。早间通知播报完毕。让我们进入这一集。今天我们要剖析的是《锦鲤池》（Koi Pond）。这是第六季第八集，由沃伦·利伯斯坦（Warren Lieberstein）和霍尔斯特德·沙利文（Halstead Sullivan）编剧，雷吉·哈德林（Reggie Hudlin）执导。以下是剧情梗概。非常简单。
It really is. But it packs a big splash. Michael falls into a Koi Pond while out for a meeting and becomes the butt of many office jokes. Meanwhile, Pam and Andy go out on mandated cold calls and are mistaken for a married couple all day. A married couple expecting a baby. A very funny runner.
It really is. But it packs a big splash. Michael falls into a Koi Pond while out for a meeting and becomes the butt of many office jokes. Meanwhile, Pam and Andy go out on mandated cold calls and are mistaken for a married couple all day. A married couple expecting a baby. A very funny runner.|||确实如此。但它闹出了不小的动静。迈克尔在出门开会时掉进了一个锦鲤池，成了办公室许多笑话的笑柄。与此同时，帕姆和安迪外出进行例行的冷拜访，一整天都被误认为是一对已婚夫妇。一对期待着宝宝出生的已婚夫妇。一个非常有趣的副线。
I enjoyed it. Fast fact number one. This episode was directed by legend Reggie Hudlin. You know, it happened from time to time on the office when we would get these directors that you just can't believe that they are directing your television show. Yeah. And Reggie was one of them. So Reggie wrote and directed the film House Party.
I enjoyed it. Fast fact number one. This episode was directed by legend Reggie Hudlin. You know, it happened from time to time on the office when we would get these directors that you just can't believe that they are directing your television show. Yeah. And Reggie was one of them. So Reggie wrote and directed the film House Party.|||我很喜欢。速查事实一。这一集的导演是传奇人物雷吉·哈德林。你知道的，在《办公室》拍摄期间，偶尔会有这种导演加入，让你简直不敢相信他们在执导你的电视剧。是的。雷吉就是其中之一。雷吉编剧并执导了电影《家庭派对》（House Party）。
He directed the film Boomerang. He directed 11 episodes of the Bernie Mac show. He was the president of Black Entertainment Television for three years. And he went on to be a producer on Quentin Tarantino's Django Unchained, which was nominated for Best Picture at the Academy Awards. Reggie was amazing to work with. He was just great. And in addition to all of his professional accomplishments, his family history is amazing.
He directed the film Boomerang. He directed 11 episodes of the Bernie Mac show. He was the president of Black Entertainment Television for three years. And he went on to be a producer on Quentin Tarantino's Django Unchained, which was nominated for Best Picture at the Academy Awards. Reggie was amazing to work with. He was just great. And in addition to all of his professional accomplishments, his family history is amazing.|||他执导了电影《回旋镖》（Boomerang）。他执导了11集的《伯尼·麦克秀》（The Bernie Mac Show）。他曾担任黑人娱乐电视台（Black Entertainment Television）的总裁三年。后来，他担任了昆汀·塔伦蒂诺的《被解救的姜戈》（Django Unchained）的制片人，该片获得了奥斯卡最佳影片提名。与雷吉合作简直棒极了。他实在太棒了。除了他所有的职业成就之外，他的家族史也令人惊叹。
I knew a little bit of it, but I didn't know everything in researching this episode. I went to his website and his bio, his family bio is worth a read. I will give you the highlights. His family grew up in East St. Louis. His great, great grandparents were Peter and Nancy Hudlin, who were part of the Underground Railroad. His great uncle was a very famous tennis instructor who mentored Arthur Ashe and Althea Gibson. Reggie attended Harvard University where he graduated magna cum laude with a BA in visual
I knew a little bit of it, but I didn't know everything in researching this episode. I went to his website and his bio, his family bio is worth a read. I will give you the highlights. His family grew up in East St. Louis. His great, great grandparents were Peter and Nancy Hudlin, who were part of the Underground Railroad. His great uncle was a very famous tennis instructor who mentored Arthur Ashe and Althea Gibson. Reggie attended Harvard University where he graduated magna cum laude with a BA in visual|||我对这有一些了解，但在为这一集做资料收集时，我并没有了解全部。我访问了他的网站和他的个人简介，他的家族简介非常值得一读。我给你们讲讲重点。他的家族在东圣路易斯长大。他的曾曾祖父母是彼得和南希·哈德林，他们是地下铁路（Underground Railroad）的参与者。他的曾叔父是一位非常著名的网球教练，曾指导过亚瑟·阿什（Arthur Ashe）和阿尔西娅·吉布森（Althea Gibson）。雷吉就读于哈佛大学，并以优异成绩（magna cum laude）毕业，获得视觉学士学位，
and in environmental studies. And it was at Harvard that he directed his thesis project, which was a short film version of House Party. It was inspired by his experience growing up in East St. Louis. And that short film became the basis of his feature film, House Party. Well, we reached out to Warren and Halstead, the writers of this episode. They are going to share awesome, awesome stuff with us. We can't wait to share with you.
and in environmental studies. And it was at Harvard that he directed his thesis project, which was a short film version of House Party. It was inspired by his experience growing up in East St. Louis. And that short film became the basis of his feature film, House Party. Well, we reached out to Warren and Halstead, the writers of this episode. They are going to share awesome, awesome stuff with us. We can't wait to share with you.|||以及环境研究学位。正是在哈佛大学，他执导了他的毕业论文项目，也就是短片版的《家庭派对》。它的灵感来自于他在东圣路易斯长大的经历。而那部短片成为了他后来长片电影《家庭派对》的基础。嗯，我们联系了这一集的编剧沃伦和霍尔斯特德。他们将与我们分享超棒超棒的内容。我们迫不及待地想与大家分享。
Warren said that one of the perks of writing on the office was being able to meet some of the people in the industry you really admired. He was a big fan of House Party and Boomerang. So he was thrilled Reggie was going to direct the episode. And he said Reggie was, quote, all class and we had a great week together. It was an honor working with him. Yeah. And Halstead also mentioned working with Reggie when we reached out.
Warren said that one of the perks of writing on the office was being able to meet some of the people in the industry you really admired. He was a big fan of House Party and Boomerang. So he was thrilled Reggie was going to direct the episode. And he said Reggie was, quote, all class and we had a great week together. It was an honor working with him. Yeah. And Halstead also mentioned working with Reggie when we reached out.|||沃伦说，为《办公室》写剧本的好处之一，就是能够见到一些你在业内真正钦佩的人。他是《家庭派对》和《回旋镖》的超级粉丝。所以当得知雷吉要执导这一集时，他兴奋极了。他说雷吉“非常有风度，我们度过了非常棒的一周。能和他合作是我的荣幸”。是的。当我们联系霍尔斯特德时，他也提到了与雷吉的合作。
And he just said that Reggie had an amazing sense of humor and he knew how to land the jokes. And he also said that Reggie was a great storyteller. He said he doesn't think he told stories with the intention of Halstead repeating any of them on a podcast. But he just wanted to say that he was really great to work with and he'd really like to work with him again. I feel the same way.
And he just said that Reggie had an amazing sense of humor and he knew how to land the jokes. And he also said that Reggie was a great storyteller. He said he doesn't think he told stories with the intention of Halstead repeating any of them on a podcast. But he just wanted to say that he was really great to work with and he'd really like to work with him again. I feel the same way.|||他只是说雷吉拥有惊人的幽默感，并且他知道如何把笑话讲响。他还说雷吉是个绝佳的故事大王。他说他觉得雷吉讲故事并不是为了让霍尔斯特德在播客里重复它们。但他只是想说，与雷吉合作真的很棒，他非常希望能再次与他合作。我也深有同感。
I mean, I just have wonderful memories of doing this episode. Same. All right. Now for fast fact number two, and Warren shared with us that there was a very, very unique writing style for this episode and I found it totally fascinating. He said that with most episodes of the office and including most shows he's ever worked on, they lay out the story on index cards, which we've talked about. You love the index cards on the wall of the writer's room.
I mean, I just have wonderful memories of doing this episode. Same. All right. Now for fast fact number two, and Warren shared with us that there was a very, very unique writing style for this episode and I found it totally fascinating. He said that with most episodes of the office and including most shows he's ever worked on, they lay out the story on index cards, which we've talked about. You love the index cards on the wall of the writer's room.|||我的意思是，我对拍摄这一集有着美好的回忆。我也是。好的。现在是速查事实二，沃伦与我们分享说，这一集有一种非常非常独特的写作风格，我觉得这完全令人着迷。他说，对于《办公室》的大多数剧集，包括他参与过的大多数节目，他们都会把故事写在索引卡片上，我们之前讨论过这个。你很喜欢编剧室墙上的索引卡片。
I love an organizational technique. But he said that for the most part, the only thing you write down on those cards are just the main beats of the story and you can move them around, you know, and then you figure out the flow and then you make an outline and you use that outline to make your first draft of the script. But with Koi Pond, Warren shared that so much of what they were telling was a subtextual story between Michael and Jim that Greg had them do something different when they were writing this episode.
I love an organizational technique. But he said that for the most part, the only thing you write down on those cards are just the main beats of the story and you can move them around, you know, and then you figure out the flow and then you make an outline and you use that outline to make your first draft of the script. But with Koi Pond, Warren shared that so much of what they were telling was a subtextual story between Michael and Jim that Greg had them do something different when they were writing this episode.|||我喜欢这种组织技巧。但他说，在大多数情况下，你写在这些卡片上的唯一东西只是故事的主要节拍，你可以移动它们，你知道的，然后你找出故事流向，接着做一个大纲，并利用这个大纲来写出剧本的第一稿。但在《锦鲤池》这一集中，沃伦分享说，他们讲述的很大一部分内容是迈克尔和吉姆之间的潜台词故事，因此格雷格让他们在写这一集时做了一些不同的事情。
He said that they had to write the main story beats on white note cards and then they wrote all of the subtext on pink note cards. So anything that Michael and Jim were feeling went on pink and like plot went on white. And he said it was really helpful for this episode and he gave some examples. So he said early on, Michael has a talking head where he wants to insult Jim and he starts off by saying that if Jim wants to be the boss, then he'll have to wear Michael's suit, which would be too small for him. But then Michael stops and he admits that, you know, Jim would probably still look good
He said that they had to write the main story beats on white note cards and then they wrote all of the subtext on pink note cards. So anything that Michael and Jim were feeling went on pink and like plot went on white. And he said it was really helpful for this episode and he gave some examples. So he said early on, Michael has a talking head where he wants to insult Jim and he starts off by saying that if Jim wants to be the boss, then he'll have to wear Michael's suit, which would be too small for him. But then Michael stops and he admits that, you know, Jim would probably still look good|||他说，他们必须把主要的故事节拍写在白色的便签卡上，然后把所有的潜台词写在粉红色的便签卡上。所以迈克尔和吉姆感受到的任何东西都写在粉色卡片上，而情节则写在白色卡片上。他说这对他这一集的创作非常有用，并举了一些例子。所以他说，在早期，迈克尔有一个单人采访镜头，他想羞辱吉姆，他一开始说，如果吉姆想当老板，那他就得穿迈克尔的西装，但这套西装对吉姆来说太小了。但接着迈克尔停了下来，他承认，你知道的，吉姆穿上可能还是会很好看
in it. Yeah, it's so great. He's like, damn it, he'd still look good. So the text is that he's mad at Jim, but the subtext is that he's still envious of him. So envy went on the pink card. And then of course, at the very end of the episode, Michael gets to have this talking head where he realizes that, wait, Jim is actually jealous of him. And so I just thought that was really, really interesting, the idea of mapping out the subtext.
in it. Yeah, it's so great. He's like, damn it, he'd still look good. So the text is that he's mad at Jim, but the subtext is that he's still envious of him. So envy went on the pink card. And then of course, at the very end of the episode, Michael gets to have this talking head where he realizes that, wait, Jim is actually jealous of him. And so I just thought that was really, really interesting, the idea of mapping out the subtext.|||的。是的，这太棒了。他就像是说：“妈的，他穿起来还是很好看。”所以表面的台词是他生吉姆的气，但潜台词是他依然嫉妒吉姆。所以“嫉妒”这张卡片写在了粉色卡片上。然后当然，在这一集的最后，迈克尔有一个单人采访镜头，他意识到，等等，其实吉姆在嫉妒他。所以我只是觉得把潜台词具象化这个想法真的非常非常有趣。
I love that. I mean, that's something we would do in our scripts as actors, like our actory homework. We would get a script with like a paragraph that's like, Angela is mean to Oscar, right? And there's a speech where she's mean to Oscar, but the subtext is, Philip was turned away from daycare, right? So she's coming in with like shame and embarrassment. So in her angry speech to Oscar about him using her stapler, the subtext is Angela's embarrassed.
I love that. I mean, that's something we would do in our scripts as actors, like our actory homework. We would get a script with like a paragraph that's like, Angela is mean to Oscar, right? And there's a speech where she's mean to Oscar, but the subtext is, Philip was turned away from daycare, right? So she's coming in with like shame and embarrassment. So in her angry speech to Oscar about him using her stapler, the subtext is Angela's embarrassed.|||我喜欢这样。我的意思是，这是我们作为演员在剧本中会做的事情，就像我们的演员作业一样。我们会拿到一个剧本，里面有一段话大致是：安吉拉对奥斯卡很尖酸刻薄，对吧？有一段台词是她对奥斯卡很刻薄，但潜台词是：菲利普被日托中心拒绝接收了，对吧？所以她带着羞耻和尴尬的情绪出场。因此在她对奥斯卡使用她订书机一事发火的台词中，潜台词其实是安吉拉感到很尴尬。
Right? Yeah. So we would do that kind of thing. But I love that they did that in the writer's room too. It's like a really cool creative writing exercise. Yeah. Well, Angela, this brings us to fast fact number three. Oh, I'm so excited for fast fact number three.
Right? Yeah. So we would do that kind of thing. But I love that they did that in the writer's room too. It's like a really cool creative writing exercise. Yeah. Well, Angela, this brings us to fast fact number three. Oh, I'm so excited for fast fact number three.|||对吧？是的。所以我们会做这种事。但我很高兴他们在编剧室里也这么做了。这就像是一个非常酷的创意写作练习。是的。好吧，安吉拉，这就让我们来到了速查事实三。噢，我太期待速查事实三了。
This is not Angela's digital clutter this week, folks. Sorry to disappoint. Guys, the plot of Michael falling into a koi pond while on his way to a meeting is based on a real life event. This happened to Warren, you guys, the writer of this episode. And then Halstead together went on a meeting and Warren fell into a pond in a lobby. And here they are today to share the whole story with us. Yes.
This is not Angela's digital clutter this week, folks. Sorry to disappoint. Guys, the plot of Michael falling into a koi pond while on his way to a meeting is based on a real life event. This happened to Warren, you guys, the writer of this episode. And then Halstead together went on a meeting and Warren fell into a pond in a lobby. And here they are today to share the whole story with us. Yes.|||伙计们，这周可不是安吉拉的数码杂物环节。抱歉让大家失望了。伙计们，迈克尔在去开会路上掉进锦鲤池的这个情节，是基于真实生活事件改编的。这真的发生在沃伦身上，伙计们，就是这一集的编剧。然后霍尔斯特德一起去开会，沃伦掉进了大厅的一个水池里。今天他们就在这里，跟我们分享整个故事。是的。
They each sent in audio clips and they were so fun. We decided to turn them into a fully sound produced story thanks to our own Sam Kiefer. So here it is, the inspiration of Koi Pond by Warren and Halstead. Hi, my name is Warren Lieberstein and along with Halstead Sullivan, we wrote the Koi Pond episode of The Office. The idea for the story stemmed from my falling into a Koi Pond. What happened was our agents set up a meeting for Halstead and I on the west side of Los Angeles.
They each sent in audio clips and they were so fun. We decided to turn them into a fully sound produced story thanks to our own Sam Kiefer. So here is the inspiration of Koi Pond by Warren and Halstead. Hi, my name is Warren Lieberstein and along with Halstead Sullivan, we wrote the Koi Pond episode of The Office. The idea for the story stemmed from my falling into a Koi Pond. What happened was our agents set up a meeting for Halstead and I on the west side of Los Angeles.|||他们每个人都发来了音频剪辑，太有趣了。多亏了我们自己的山姆·基弗（Sam Kiefer），我们决定把它制作成一个配有完整音效的故事。所以，这就是沃伦和霍尔斯特德讲述的《锦鲤池》的灵感来源。嗨，我叫沃伦·利伯斯坦，我和霍尔斯特德·沙利文一起编写了《办公室》的《锦鲤池》这一集。这个故事的创意源于我掉进了一个锦鲤池。事情是这样的，我们的经纪人安排我和霍尔斯特德在洛杉矶西区开个会。
It was in this nice two-story office building. There was a marble reception, an open atrium lobby, there were these dark tavern teen floors. So we enter into this building for the meeting and I'm chewing gum and I can't go to a meeting chewing gum. That's horribly unprofessional and so I'm immediately looking for a trash can. Warren and I walk in for this meeting and I head over to the receptionist just to announce her names and Warren says, oh, I'm going to go throw away my gum. I see a trash can by the staircase off the corner so I walk over.
It was in this nice two-story office building. There was a marble reception, an open atrium lobby, there were these dark tavern teen floors. So we enter into this building for the meeting and I'm chewing gum and I can't go to a meeting chewing gum. That's horribly unprofessional and so I'm immediately looking for a trash can. Warren and I walk in for this meeting and I head over to the receptionist just to announce her names and Warren says, oh, I'm going to go throw away my gum. I see a trash can by the staircase off the corner so I walk over.|||那是一栋漂亮的双层办公楼。大堂有大理石前台、开放式中庭，还有那种深色的石灰华（travertine）地面。于是我们走进这栋大楼去开会，我当时正在嚼口香糖，我可不能嚼着口香糖去开会。那极其不专业，所以我立刻在找垃圾桶。沃伦和我走进来开会，我走向前台接待员去报上我们的名字，而沃伦说：“哦，我要去扔一下口香糖。”我看到角落楼梯旁有个垃圾桶，于是我就走了过去。
After I toss my gum in the trash, I turn and pivot on my right foot. My right foot somehow though doesn't reach the floor. So while I'm there at the desk, you know, checking in, suddenly I hear this huge splash. So my right foot doesn't find the floor and I lose my balance and I'm falling backwards. This point, real concerns that I'm falling to my death, down an open stairwell or whatever. My legs did it first and I have no idea what size tank of water I'm falling into. In this millisecond, I now believe I'm falling into a shark tank and I'm definitely going to die by shark attack.
After I toss my gum in the trash, I turn and pivot on my right foot. My right foot somehow though doesn't reach the floor. So while I'm there at the desk, you know, checking in, suddenly I hear this huge splash. So my right foot doesn't find the floor and I lose my balance and I'm falling backwards. This point, real concerns that I'm falling to my death, down an open stairwell or whatever. My legs did it first and I have no idea what size tank of water I'm falling into. In this millisecond, I now believe I'm falling into a shark tank and I'm definitely going to die by shark attack.|||当我把口香糖扔进垃圾桶后，我转身以右脚为轴旋转。不知怎么的，我的右脚竟然没有踩到地面。所以，当我正在前台那里办理登记时，突然我听到“哗啦”一声巨响。我的右脚没有踩到地面，我失去了平衡，向后倒去。那一刻，我真的担心自己会摔死，顺着开放式的楼梯间或者其他什么地方掉下去。我的双腿先着地，我完全不知道自己掉进了一个多大的水箱里。在这一毫秒内，我当时坚信自己掉进了一个鲨鱼池，我肯定会被鲨鱼袭击而死。
But after a second or so, I realize, obviously I'm in a koi pond. I just nesty plunged into it. I am adrenched and all I can say over and over again is, oh my god, oh, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god. Halstead turns around and sees me, Warren is basically like lying in the pond splashing going, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, I'm like, Warren, Warren, Warren. As Warren sitting there splashing in the pond, we look up, of course, everyone comes out of their offices to see what the commotion is.
But after a second or so, I realize, obviously I'm in a koi pond. I just nesty plunged into it. I am adrenched and all I can say over and over again is, oh my god, oh, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god. Halstead turns around and sees me, Warren is basically like lying in the pond splashing going, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, I'm like, Warren, Warren, Warren. As Warren sitting there splashing in the pond, we look up, of course, everyone comes out of their offices to see what the commotion is.|||但在大约一秒钟后，我意识到，很显然我是在一个锦鲤池里。我刚刚“呼啦”一下一头扎了进去。我湿透了，我嘴里只能一遍又一遍地重复着：“哦我的天哪，哦，哦我的天哪，哦我的天哪，哦我的天哪。”霍尔斯特德转过身来看到我，沃伦基本上就像是躺在水池里溅着水花喊着：“哦我的天哪，哦我的天哪，哦我的天哪”，而我就在喊：“沃伦，沃伦，沃伦。”正当沃伦坐在水池里溅起水花时，我们抬头一看，理所当然地，每个人都从他们的办公室里走出来看外面发生了什么动静。
So basically everyone in this building is now staring and on the railing, they're like eight people looking over, you know, on the first floor, all these people have come out to see all the commotion. My favorite part of Warren's description is the nesty plunge into the koi pond and also just like how disorienting that is. Yeah. Like it's going to take you a minute. It's so many things, it's like I'm falling, I'm wet, why am I wet, where am I?
So basically everyone in this building is now staring and on the railing, they're like eight people looking over, you know, on the first floor, all these people have come out to see all the commotion. My favorite part of Warren's description is the nesty plunge into the koi pond and also just like how disorienting that is. Yeah. Like it's going to take you a minute. It's so many things, it's like I'm falling, I'm wet, why am I wet, where am I?|||所以基本上这栋大楼里的所有人现在都在盯着看，栏杆上大概有八个人正探出头往下看，你知道的，在一楼，所有这些人全都跑出来看这阵骚动。我最喜欢沃伦描述的那个词，就是“呼啦”一声扎进锦鲤池，还有那种极其晕头转向的感觉。是的。就像这需要你缓上一分钟。事情太多了，感觉就像我在下坠，我湿了，我为什么会湿，我在哪儿？
So I'm drenched and there's so much water on this nice lobby floor. And someone comes up to us with a roll of those brown paper towels that you get from the bathroom, you know, they're just basically made of manila paper and have zero absorbency. And it's like, okay, thanks. At this point, they leave, right? Because Warren is soaking wet. That's what you would think, Jenna, but you have to remember, we all live in Los Angeles and they had driven really far for this meeting.
So I'm drenched and there's so much water on this nice lobby floor. And someone comes up to us with a roll of those brown paper towels that you get from the bathroom, you know, they're just basically made of manila paper and have zero absorbency. And it's like, okay, thanks. At this point, they leave, right? Because Warren is soaking wet. That's what you would think, Jenna, but you have to remember, we all live in Los Angeles and they had driven really far for this meeting.|||所以我浑身湿透了，这个漂亮的大堂地板上洒满了水。然后有人拿着一卷从洗手间拿的那种棕色纸巾朝我们走过来，你知道的，它们基本上就是牛皮纸做的，吸水性为零。然后就像是说：“好吧，谢谢。”到了这个时候，他们应该离开了吧？因为沃伦浑身湿透了。珍娜，你肯定会这么想，但你得记住，我们都住在洛杉矶，他们为了这个会议开了很长一段车。
They actually offer us to move the meeting for a week later, but Halstead wanted to keep the meeting because, you know, for those who don't live in LA, going to the west side, no one wants to cross the 405 ever. The 405 is a highway and no matter what side of it you're on, traveling to the other is like a traffic nightmare. We know that around the corner is a sporting goods store. So we go there, you know, we walk in, Warren's soaking wet. I'm sopping wet.
They actually offer us to move the meeting for a week later, but Halstead wanted to keep the meeting because, you know, for those who don't live in LA, going to the west side, no one wants to cross the 405 ever. The 405 is a highway and no matter what side of it you're on, traveling to the other is like a traffic nightmare. We know that around the corner is a sporting goods store. So we go there, you know, we walk in, Warren's soaking wet. I'm sopping wet.|||他们实际上提出把会议推迟一周，但霍尔斯特德想把会议按时进行，因为，你知道的，对于不住在洛杉矶的人来说，去西区的话，没有人愿意去横穿405号公路。405号公路是一条高速公路，无论你在它的哪一侧，去到另一侧都像是一场交通噩梦。我们知道拐角处有一家体育用品商店。所以我们去了那里，你知道的，我们走了进去，沃伦浑身湿透。我湿透了。
There was these two women working there and I looked insane, like Jim Carrey in Ace Ventura when he comes out of the bathroom. Water's pouring all over their floor and I just say, I need one of everything. We go back to the meeting and Halstead looks, you know, great per usual, you know, it's his normal meeting outfit. And I look like a rap star from the 80s. It was a sports clothing store, so, you know, I could get really was a track suit. But we take the meeting and of course all we can really talk about is me falling into
There was these two women working there and I looked insane, like Jim Carrey in Ace Ventura when he comes out of the bathroom. Water's pouring all over their floor and I just say, I need one of everything. We go back to the meeting and Halstead looks, you know, great per usual, you know, it's his normal meeting outfit. And I look like a rap star from the 80s. It was a sports clothing store, so, you know, I could get really was a track suit. But we take the meeting and of course all we can really talk about is me falling into|||那里有两个女员工在上班，我看起来疯了似的，就像《神探飞机头》（Ace Ventura）里的金·凯瑞从浴室出来时的样子。水哗啦哗啦地流满她们的地板，我直接就说：“每样东西我都要一件。”我们回到会议室，霍尔斯特德看起来呢，一如既往地帅气，你知道的，那是他正常的开会着装。而我看起来像个80年代的说唱歌手。那是一家运动服装店，所以，你知道的，我能买到的其实是一套运动服。但我们还是去开会了，当然我们实际上能谈论的全部内容就是我掉进了
the koi pun and the puns were flying, you know, they kept asking if I needed more water to do, you know, all of it and we, we used all that in the script. And then after the meeting, my agent called and said, I heard you made a splash at the meeting, which is a line that Aaron says in the show. So that is the koi pun story. Life imitates art, art imitates life and you make an office episode out of it. Sam, you crushed it. That was so much fun.
the koi pun and the puns were flying, you know, they kept asking if I need more water to do, you know, all of it and we, we used all that in the script. And then after the meeting, my agent called and said, I heard you made a splash at the meeting, which is a line that Aaron says in the show. So that is the koi pun story. Life imitates art, art imitates life and you make an office episode out of it. Sam, you crushed it. That was so much fun.|||锦鲤池里，双关语满天飞，你知道的，他们一直问我是不是需要更多水来做，你知道的，所有这些，我们把这些全都用到了剧本里。然后会议结束后，我的经纪人打电话来说：“我听说你在会上引起了轰动（made a splash）”，这也是剧中艾伦说的一句台词。这就是锦鲤池的故事。生活模仿艺术，艺术模仿生活，你就能用它拍出一集《办公室》。山姆，你太棒了。这太有趣了。
Yes, Sam, that was so good. Oh my gosh. And I just have to say, Warren, I'm so glad you fell in the koi pond because I'm so glad it got turned into an episode that I thoroughly enjoyed. And you know what? This is what artists do. They take moments from their life and they turn it into art. Thank you, Warren.
Yes, Sam, that was so good. Oh my gosh. And I just have to say, Warren, I'm so glad you fell in the koi pond because I'm so glad it got turned into an episode that I thoroughly enjoyed. And you know what? This is what artists do. They take moments from their life and they turn it into art. Thank you, Warren.|||是的，山姆，太棒了。噢天哪。我只想说，沃伦，我真高兴你掉进了锦鲤池，因为我太高兴它能变成一集我非常喜爱的电视剧了。你知道吗？这就是艺术家们所做的事。他们截取生活中的片断，然后将其转化为艺术。谢谢你，沃伦。
Absolutely. I remember when it happened, you know, Warren is my ex-husband and we're still very good friends and I remember saying, you know what? This will be a great story someday and it was and it still is. Yes. Well, on that note, I think we should take a break and then we'll come back and we'll get into this episode. Sounds great.
Absolutely. I remember when it happened, you know, Warren is my ex-husband and we're still very good friends and I remember saying, you know what? This will be a great story someday and it was and it still is. Yes. Well, on that note, I think we should take a break and then we'll come back and we'll get into this episode. Sounds great.|||当然。我记得事情发生的时候，你知道的，沃伦是我的前夫，我们现在依然是非常好的朋友，我记得当时我说：“你知道吗？总有一天这会是一个绝妙的故事。”事实也确实如此，现在依然是。是的。好了，借此机会，我觉得我们应该休息一下，然后回来继续剖析这一集。听起来不错。
Let's get started this week with a fan question, Angela. Great. This comes from Tom W. in San Francisco, California, who says, whenever this episode airs on direct TV cable, the on-screen guide summarizes it as, quote, the office plans a haunted house for children in the community. But there's no mention of a haunted house in the episode or deleted scenes or in any other episode that I can remember. Was this a storyline that the writers chose not to pursue?
Let's get started this week with a fan question, Angela. Great. This comes from Tom W. in San Francisco, California, who says, whenever this episode airs on direct TV cable, the on-screen guide summarizes it as, quote, the office plans a haunted house for children in the community. But there's no mention of a haunted house in the episode or deleted scenes or in any other episode that I can remember. Was this a storyline that the writers chose not to pursue?|||安吉拉，这周我们先从一个粉丝提问开始吧。太棒了。这个问题来自加利福尼亚州旧金山的汤姆·W（Tom W.），他说：每当这一集在DirecTV有线电视上播出时，屏幕上的节目指南将其概括为：“办公室为社区的孩子们策划了一个鬼屋。”但在这一集、删减片段中，或者据我所能记起的任何其他剧集里，都没有提到过鬼屋。这是编剧们选择放弃不拍的故事线吗？
Well, Tom, here is your answer. This episode originally had a Halloween cold open. We shot it and it actually aired because this episode came out the week of Halloween. And there is a haunted house in the warehouse and Michael fake hangs himself in the haunted house. And after it aired, NBC decided to pull it from all future episodes. So that's why you're seeing it in your description, but the cold open is not there anymore. It's also not on the DVDs in the deleted scene section.
Well, Tom, here is your answer. This episode originally had a Halloween cold open. We shot it and it actually aired because this episode came out the week of Halloween. And there is a haunted house in the warehouse and Michael fake hangs himself in the haunted house. And after it aired, NBC decided to pull it from all future episodes. So that's why you're seeing it in your description, but the cold open is not there anymore. It's also not on the DVDs in the deleted scene section.|||嗯，汤姆，这就是你的答案。这一集原本有一个万圣节冷开场。我们拍了它，而且它确实播出了，因为这一集是在万圣节当周播出的。仓库里有一个鬼屋，迈克尔在鬼屋里假装上吊。播出后，全国广播公司（NBC）决定将其从所有未来的剧集播放中撤下。所以这就是为什么你会在节目描述里看到它，但冷开场已经不在了。它也不在DVD的删减片段部分中。
There are photos of the cast and their costumes from this episode online. I was a spider, Mindy was Lelou from Fifth Element. Yeah. I think this is the one where Jim is Facebook, but he just wrote book on his face for Facebook. That's right. But anyway, guys, instead, this episode opens in Jim's office. And Michael is sharing about his plans for the weekend. Yeah.
There are photos of the cast and their costumes from this episode online. I was a spider, Mindy was Lelou from Fifth Element. Yeah. I think this is the one where Jim is Facebook, but he just wrote book on his face for Facebook. That's right. But anyway, guys, instead, this episode opens in Jim's office. And Michael is sharing about his plans for the weekend. Yeah.|||网上有这一集中演员及其服装的照片。我扮演的是一只蜘蛛，敏迪扮演的是《第五元素》（Fifth Element）里的莉露（Lelou）。对。我想这一集里吉姆扮成了Facebook（脸书），但他只是在脸上写了“书”（book）来代表Facebook。没错。但无论如何，伙计们，相反，这一集是从吉姆的办公室开始的。迈克尔正在分享他周末的计划。是的。
He's going to go to a garlic festival. That's a real thing, lady. Is it? There is a Pocono garlic and harvest festival. I looked it up. It is held every year on Labor Day weekend in the Shawnee Mountain Ski area. The festival is Saturday and Sunday. Angela, I think we have to go.
He's going to go to a garlic festival. That's a real thing, lady. Is it? There is a Pocono garlic and harvest festival. I looked it up. It is held every year on Labor Day weekend in the Shawnee Mountain Ski area. The festival is Saturday and Sunday. Angela, I think we have to go.|||他要去参加一个大蒜节。女士，这可是真事。是吗？有一个波科诺大蒜丰收节（Pocono Garlic and Harvest Festival）。我查过了。它每年在劳动节周末在肖尼山滑雪场（Shawnee Mountain Ski Area）举行。这个节日为期周六和周日两天。安吉拉，我觉得我们必须去。
I was just, I was about to say it. I know I say that every time you bring up one of these things, but I am telling you, I would love a garlic festival. I bet they have all kinds of things made from garlic. Lady, listen to what your ticket price includes. I can't wait. Four stages of continuous live music. Great.
I was just, I was about to say it. I know I say that every time you bring up one of these things, but I am telling you, I would love a garlic festival. I bet they have all kinds of things made from garlic. Lady, listen to what your ticket price includes. I can't wait. Four stages of continuous live music. Great.|||我正——我正想说呢。我知道每次你提起这类事情我都会这么说，但我告诉你，我太喜欢大蒜节了。我敢打赌他们有各种用大蒜做成的东西。女士，听听你的门票包含什么内容。我等不及了。四个不间断的现场音乐舞台。太棒了。
Professional chef cooking demonstrations. Ding, ding, ding. Farmer garlic growing seminars, as well as children's craft activities. Can adults do the craft activities? I was going to say, you got to have a craft table at a festival. I found out that Pennsylvania is home to something called hardneck garlic. Hardneck garlic, it's a type of garlic. And there are three main types of hardneck garlic.
Professional chef cooking demonstrations. Ding, ding, ding. Farmer garlic growing seminars, as well as children's craft activities. Can adults do the craft activities? I was going to say, you got to have a craft table at a festival. I found out that Pennsylvania is home to something called hardneck garlic. Hardneck garlic, it's a type of garlic. And there are three main types of hardneck garlic.|||专业大厨烹饪演示。叮，叮，叮。农民大蒜种植研讨会，以及儿童手工艺活动。大人可以参加手工艺活动吗？我本来想说，你去参加这种节日，总得有个手工桌。我发现宾夕法尼亚州有一种叫做“硬颈大蒜”（hardneck garlic）的东西。硬颈大蒜，这是一种大蒜。硬颈大蒜主要有三种类型。
They are rock'n'bowley, if I'm pronouncing that correctly. It has a rich full-bodied taste and it'll last up to six months. There's porcelain hardneck garlic. That'll stay good up to eight months and then there's purple stripe hardneck garlic. And it's famous for making the best baked garlic. It has a distinctive bright purple streak on that papery sheath. I've seen that. Well, if you need to bake your garlic, you're going to want to buy that purple stripe garlic.
They are rock'n'bowley, if I'm pronouncing that correctly. It has a rich full-bodied taste and it'll last up to six months. There's porcelain hardneck garlic. That's'll stay good up to eight months and then there's purple stripe hardneck garlic. And it's famous for making the best baked garlic. It has a distinctive bright purple streak on that papery sheath. I've seen that. Well, if you need to bake your garlic, you're going to want to buy that purple stripe garlic.|||它们是rock'n'bowley，如果我发音正确的话。它具有浓郁醇厚的口感，可以保存长达六个月。还有瓷白硬颈大蒜（porcelain hardneck garlic）。这种大蒜可以保鲜长达八个月，然后是紫条纹硬颈大蒜（purple stripe hardneck garlic）。它以制作最美味的烤大蒜而闻名。在那薄如纸的外皮上有着标志性的亮紫色条纹。我见过那个。嗯，如果你需要烤大蒜，你就会想买那种紫条纹大蒜。
Okay. Anyway, Michael's going to the garlic festival. He's also very excited because there is a TCBY booth. I remember us all going to get yogurt. There was this like yogurt phase. I think it's still happening, obviously, right? There's lots of yogurt places. But I feel like TCBY was the first one where we were all like, oh my gosh, let's go get
Okay. Anyway, Michael's going to the garlic festival. He's also very excited because there is a TCBY booth. I remember us all going to get yogurt. There was this like yogurt phase. I think it's still happening, obviously, right? There's lots of yogurt places. But I feel like TCBY was the first one where we were all like, oh my gosh, let's go get|||好吧。不管怎样，迈克尔要去大蒜节。他也很兴奋，因为那里有一个TCBY酸奶摊。我记得我们大家一起去买酸奶。当时正处于那种酸奶热潮中。我想现在显然也还在流行，对吧？有很多酸奶店。但我感觉TCBY是第一家让我们所有人都忍不住说“哦天哪，我们去买”的店。
yogurt. No, Steve used to come to work. Very excited when he found a new frozen yogurt place. He was especially into it. I feel like this line maybe came from that real life obsession. It was a thing. It did crack me up that Michael says, yeah, it stands for I can't believe it's yogurt. Yeah.
yogurt. No, Steve used to come to work. Very excited when he found a new frozen yogurt place. He was especially into it. I feel like this line maybe came from that real life obsession. It was a thing. It did crack me up that Michael says, yeah, it stands for I can't believe it's yogurt. Yeah.|||酸奶。不，史蒂夫以前来上班时。每当他发现一家新的冷冻酸奶店，他就会非常兴奋。他特别迷恋这个。我觉得这句台词可能就源于这种现实生活中的痴迷。确实有这么回事。迈克尔说“对，它代表‘我真不敢相信这是酸奶’（I can't believe it's yogurt）”，这真的把我逗笑了。是的。
But it's TCBY. I looked it up, Jenna. And it actually stands for the country's best yogurt, TCBY, the country's best yogurt. There used to be one in Scranton per the internet in the fashion mall, but it's no longer there. There you go. Erin is going to interrupt all of this talk of garlic and TCBY to say that Raskin Design called and is expecting both of them for their meeting in an hour. And Jim's like, hold up, it's just me.
But it's TCBY. I looked it up, Jenna. And it actually stands for the country's best yogurt, TCBY, the country's best yogurt. There used to be one in Scranton per the internet in the fashion mall, but it's no longer there. There you go. Erin is going to interrupt all of this talk of garlic and TCBY to say that Raskin Design called and is expecting both of them for their meeting in an hour. And Jim's like, hold up, it's just me.|||但其实它是TCBY。珍娜，我查过了。它实际上代表“全国最好的酸奶”（the country's best yogurt），TCBY就是全国最好的酸奶。根据网上的资料，斯克兰顿的时尚购物中心（fashion mall）里曾经有一家，但现在已经不在了。就是这样。埃林打断了所有关于大蒜和TCBY的讨论，说拉askin设计公司（Raskin Design）打来电话，希望他们两人在一小时后来开会。吉姆说：“等等，只有我一个人去。”
Michael is delighted that they want him to tag along. Yeah, I know. He's like, really? Oh, they want me as well. Oh, wow. He's all like playing like he's not delighted. That must have been a pink card. Pink card.
Michael is delighted that they want him to tag along. Yeah, I know. He's like, really? Oh, they want me as well. Oh, wow. He's all like playing like he's not delighted. That must have been a pink card. Pink card.|||迈克尔一听他们想让他跟着去，高兴坏了。是的，我知道。他就像是：“真的吗？哦，他们也想要我一起去吗？哦，哇。”他完全是在假装自己一点也不高兴。那张卡片肯定得是粉红色的。粉色卡片。
Michael's delighted. Yes. Well, Michael's going to try to prep Jim for this meeting. Oh, my gosh, Jenna, in deleted scenes, this was a much bigger moment. It cracked me up. Michael's like, this office is very formal, Jim. You don't just say, Dave, it's Mr. Borchard. And also, is that what you're wearing?
Michael's delighted. Yes. Well, Michael's going to try to prep Jim for this meeting. Oh, my gosh, Jenna, in deleted scenes, this was a much bigger moment. It cracked me up. Michael's like, this office is very formal, Jim. You don't just say, Dave, it's Mr. Borchard. And also, is that what you're wearing?|||迈克尔很高兴。是的。好吧，迈克尔要试着为吉姆这次会议做做准备。噢天哪，珍娜，在删减片段中，这是一个大得多的场景。把我给逗乐了。迈克尔说：“这个办公室非常正式，吉姆。你不能直接叫‘戴夫’，要叫‘博查德先生’。还有，这就是你穿的衣服吗？”
And then the scene would have continued where Michael is going to help Jim retie his tie. He says he needs a double dimple. A double dimple. Have you ever heard of this, Jenna? No. Can we hear it? Is that what you are wearing? Yes, it is.
And then the scene would have continued where Michael is going to help Jim retie his tie. He says he needs a double dimple. A double dimple. Have you ever heard of this, Jenna? No. Can we hear it? Is that what you are wearing? Yes, it is.|||然后场景本该继续，迈克尔要帮吉姆重新系领带。他说他需要一个“双酒窝”（double dimple，意指双褶领带结）。双酒窝。珍娜，你听说过这个吗？没有。我们能听听看吗？这就是你穿的衣服吗？是的，它是。
How about the knot on the tie? Double dimple. I think we need to go. No. Don't touch my... You need to double dimple your tie, Jim. Come on. Here we go.
How about the knot on the tie? Double dimple. I think we need to go. No. Don't touch my... You need to double dimple your tie, Jim. Come on. Here we go.|||领带上的结怎么样？双酒窝。我觉得我们得走了。不。别碰我的……你的领带需要打出双酒窝，吉姆。来吧。我们开始吧。
I want you to look good. I can't... Turn around. No. Come on. I can only do this in one direction. And here we go. Here we go.
I want you to look good. I can't... Turn around. No. Come on. I can only do this in one direction. And here we go. Here we go.|||我希望你看起来帅气。我不能……转过身去。不。来吧。我只能朝一个方向弄这个。好了。我们开始。
I don't want them to think that you are a country pumpkin. And up through the rabbit hole, around the merry-go-round, and up again, through the rabbit hole, and down into the gopher hole, up, up, up. How do we look? That's perfect. Okay. So, in the scene, Michael steps behind him, and Jim is so annoyed. He unties this tie that was really well tied.
I don't want them to think that you are a country pumpkin. And up through the rabbit hole, around the merry-go-round, and up again, through the rabbit hole, and down into the gopher hole, up, up, up. How do we look? That's perfect. Okay. So, in the scene, Michael steps behind him, and Jim is so annoyed. He unties this tie that was really well tied.|||我可不想让他们觉得你是个乡巴佬。从兔子洞穿上来，绕过旋转木马，再往上穿，穿过兔子洞，然后下到地鼠洞里，上，上，上。我们看起来怎么样？太完美了。好的。所以，在这场戏里，迈克尔走到他身后，吉姆烦透了。他解开了这条原本系得很好的领带。
He does this rabbit hole, gopher hole. He's very awkwardly trying to reach over Jim, who's taller than he is, right? And then when he spins him around and says, how do we look? He just looks... The tie looks horrible. Is there a double dimple now? I couldn't see a double dimple, and Jim's collar is all messed up. And it's just a really physically funny scene.
He does this rabbit hole, gopher hole. He's very awkwardly trying to reach over Jim, who's taller than he is, right? And then when he spins him around and says, how do we look? He just looks... The tie looks horrible. Is there a double dimple now? I couldn't see a double dimple, and Jim's collar is all messed up. And it's just a really physically funny scene.|||他搞出了什么兔子洞、地鼠洞。他笨拙地试图越过比他高的吉姆去够着系领带，对吧？然后当他把吉姆转过身来说“我们看起来怎么样？”时，他看起来……领带看起来糟透了。现在有双酒窝了吗？我根本看不出什么双酒窝，而且吉姆的领口全弄乱了。这真是一个充满肢体幽默的场景。
But it got me curious. What is a double dimple? Jenna, this is all over the internet. It's clearly important when it comes to tying a tie. What? Yeah. There's video tutorials. One says the perfect dimple every time.
But it got me curious. What is a double dimple? Jenna, this is all over the internet. It's clearly important when it comes to tying a tie. What? Yeah. There's video tutorials. One says the perfect dimple every time.|||但这勾起了我的好奇心。什么是双酒窝？珍娜，网上到处都是这个。在系领带时，这显然很重要。什么？是的。有视频教程。其中一个说每次都能系出完美的酒窝。
There was a quote I found online that said, dimples matter. You'll see this even in the simplest of tie knots. The four in hand. Make sure you create the dimple under the knot, otherwise your tie will look flatter and less finished. Wow. No one wants a flat tie. You need the double dimple.
There was a quote I found online that said, dimples matter. You'll see this even in the simplest of tie knots. The four in hand. Make sure you create the dimple under the knot, otherwise your tie will look flatter and less finished. Wow. No one wants a flat tie. You need the double dimple.|||我在线上找到的一句话说：“酒窝很重要。即使在最简单的领带结中你也能看到这一点。比如四手结（four in hand）。确保在领带结下方制造出酒窝，否则你的领带看起来会更扁平、更缺乏精致感。”哇。没有人想要一条扁平的领带。你需要双酒窝。
I had no idea. But it was a really cute scene where Michael is basically trying to get Jim all spiffy. Well, Michael also wants him to change his watch. He says, you need a tankered watch. I looked that up. That's not a watch. There's no such thing? There's no such thing as a tankered watch.
I had no idea. But it was a really cute scene where Michael is basically trying to get Jim all spiffy. Well, Michael also wants him to change his watch. He says, you need a tankered watch. I looked that up. That's not a watch. There's no such thing? There's no such thing as a tankered watch.|||我完全不知道。但这真的是一个非常可爱的场景，迈克尔基本上是想把吉姆打扮得利落精神。嗯，迈克尔还想让他换块表。他说：“你需要一块‘tankered’表。”我查过了。那根本不是表。没有这种东西吗？根本没有什么“tankered”表。
There is such thing as a tank watch. It's a Cartier watch. Apparently it was designed after the tanks of the World War II battlefields. It has a rectangular face. So when Michael is handing Jim this rectangular face watch, he's, I don't know, I feel like maybe someone kind of like with his fake Seiko, maybe they sold him a fake tank watch and called it a tankered. A tankered is actually a drinking stein.
There is such thing as a tank watch. It's a Cartier watch. Apparently it was designed after the tanks of the World War II battlefields. It has a rectangular face. So when Michael is handing Jim this rectangular face watch, he's, I don't know, I feel like maybe someone kind of like with his fake Seiko, maybe they sold him a fake tank watch and called it a tankered. A tankered is actually a drinking stein.|||世上倒是有“坦克表”（tank watch）这种东西。那是卡地亚（Cartier）的手表。显然它是根据第二次世界大战战场上的坦克设计的。它有一个长方形的表盘。所以当迈克尔把这块方形表盘的手表递给吉姆时，我不知道，我感觉也许有人就像卖给他假精工（Seiko）手表那样，可能卖给他一块假的坦克表，却管它叫“tankered”。“tankered”实际上是一种啤酒大酒杯（drinking stein）。
It's sort of like a beer stein. That's what a tankered is. I learned. Oh my gosh. Isn't that crazy? That is crazy. A tank watch by Cartier sells for like $4,000. Yowza.
It's sort of like a beer stein. That's what a tankered is. I learned. Oh my gosh. Isn't that crazy? That is crazy. A tank watch by Cartier sells for like $4,000. Yowza.|||它有点像啤酒杯。那就是所谓的“tankered”。我学到了。噢天哪。是不是很疯狂？太疯狂了。卡地亚的坦克表售价大约要4000美元。哇塞。
So that's clearly what Michael thinks he has purchased. He's purchased a tankered. A tankered. We're about to start a really fun runner between Pam and Andy. Jenna, this must have been a blast. You had Ed Holmes to yourself doing all these bits all day. I loved this runner. It was so much fun.
So that's clearly what Michael thinks he has purchased. He's purchased a tankered. A tankered. We're about to start a really fun runner between Pam and Andy. Jenna, this must have been a blast. You had Ed Holmes to yourself doing all these bits all day. I loved this runner. It was so much fun.|||所以这显然就是迈克尔认为自己买到的东西。他买了一个“tankered”。一个“tankered”。我们马上要开始帕姆和安迪之间一条非常有趣的副线了。珍娜，这一定太好玩了。你一整天都和埃德·赫尔姆斯（Ed Helms）独处，一起演这些桥段。我很喜欢这条副线。太有趣了。
We had the best time. You know that scene where Andy is singing the directory? I wrote it out. I wrote the whole thing out. Paloban drilling, where are you? Dean Trophy, sweet 100 and doodly-doo. Sherman Blinds and rug sweet 202, Paloban drilling. I mean, I was cracking up.
We had the best time. You know that scene where Andy is singing the directory? I wrote it out. I wrote the whole thing out. Paloban drilling, where are you? Dean Trophy, sweet 100 and doodly-doo. Sherman Blinds and rug sweet 202, Paloban drilling. I mean, I was cracking up.|||我们度过了最美好的时光。你知道安迪唱电话名录的那场戏吗？我把它写下来了。我把整段都写下来了。“帕洛班钻探（Paloban Drilling），你在哪里？迪恩奖杯（Dean Trophy），100甜蜜套间和嘟嘟噜。谢尔曼百货和地毯202甜蜜套间，帕洛班钻探。”我的意思是，我当时笑得前仰后合。
Yeah. Ed made that up. I mean, he made up that tune. He made up the whole melody. He did. He was just on the fly. And we knew that I was going to cut him off at the end with the sweet 401. Yeah.
Yeah. Ed made that up. I mean, he made up that tune. He made up the whole melody. He did. He was just on the fly. And we knew that I was going to cut him off at the end with the sweet 401. Yeah.|||是的。那是埃德现编的。我的意思是，他编了那个曲调。他编了整个旋律。是的。他当时完全是即兴发挥。而且我们知道我最后会在“401甜蜜套间”那里打断他。是的。
And then he couldn't resolve the melody and his brain hurt. Yeah. He said it felt like he was holding in a sneeze. Well, Warren shared they loved your look to camera when Andy sings sweet foe one, like as the door shut. And I have to tell you guys, you know, I've known Warren and Halstead a very long time. And they were both in acapella in college. So I have to imagine this scene was just such a fun moment for them.
And then he couldn't resolve the melody and his brain hurt. Yeah. He said it felt like he was holding in a sneeze. Well, Warren shared they loved your look to camera when Andy sings sweet foe one, like as the door shut. And I have to tell you guys, you know, I've known Warren and Halstead a very long time. And they were both in acapella in college. So I have to imagine this scene was just such a fun moment for them.|||然后他就没法把旋律收尾，脑子都快想炸了。是的。他说感觉就像在憋一个喷嚏。嗯，沃伦分享说，当安迪唱到“sweet foe one”（甜美的401）时，也就是门关上的时候，他们特别喜欢你对着镜头的那副表情。我得告诉大家，你知道的，我认识沃伦和霍尔斯特德很久了。他们俩在大学时都参加过阿卡贝拉（无伴奏合唱）社团。所以我可以想象，对他们来说，这一幕一定是个非常有趣的时刻。
I've got a location alert for my scenes with Ed. We did shoot one entire day out in Woodland Hills, California at the Warner Center Corporate Park. We did everything in this one office. So basically, they dressed two different offices, one to be palpabondrilling, and then later read Diamond Labs when we're going to meet with Miss Gifford. And we also did the driving scenes on that same day. So this was truly a full day, just me and Ed and Reggie and Warren and Halstead, basically.
I've got a location alert for my scenes with Ed. We did shoot one entire day out in Woodland Hills, California at the Warner Center Corporate Park. We did everything in this one office. So basically, they dressed two different offices, one to be palpabondrilling, and then later read Diamond Labs when we're going to meet with Miss Gifford. And we also did the driving scenes on that same day. So this was truly a full day, just me and Ed and Reggie and Warren and Halstead, basically.|||我有关于我和埃德对手戏的拍摄地点提醒。我们在加利福尼亚州伍德兰山（Woodland Hills）的华纳中心企业园（Warner Center Corporate Park）外景地整整拍了一天。我们在这间办公室里完成了所有拍摄。所以基本上，他们布置了两个不同的办公室，一个是帕洛班钻探公司，然后稍后当我们去见吉福德女士时，就变成了红钻石实验室（Red Diamond Labs）。我们在同一天还拍了开车的戏。所以这真的是满满的一天，基本上就是我和埃德、雷吉、沃伦以及霍尔斯特德在一起。
It was awesome. Back at the office, Michael and Jim returned from their meeting and Michael is soaked. I mean, he is drenched. Well, he was caught in a flash flood storm is what happened. Yeah. Jim outran it, though. Yeah. That's why he's dry.
It was awesome. Back at the office, Michael and Jim returned from their meeting and Michael is soaked. I mean, he is drenched. Well, he was caught in a flash flood storm is what happened. Yeah. Jim outran it, though. Yeah. That's why he's dry.|||太棒了。回到办公室，迈克尔和吉姆开完会回来了，迈克尔湿透了。我是说，他浑身湿透了。嗯，情况是这样的，他遭遇了一场山洪暴雨。是的。不过吉姆跑得比雨快。是的。这就是为什么他是干的。
He outran the storm. Meredith was like, no way. If there was rain, my hip would have been throbbing. I know. So I want you to note something in this scene at three minutes, 35 seconds. I have a background catch. Did you see Angela Martin's sassy wavy ponytail? No.
Meredith was like, no way. If there was rain, my hip would have been throbbing. I know. So I want you to note something in this scene at three minutes, 35 seconds. I have a background catch. Did you see Angela Martin's sassy wavy ponytail? No.|||梅雷迪思说：“不可能。如果有下雨，我的髋关节早就开始剧痛了。”我知道。所以我想让你注意这一集3分35秒时的某个细节。我抓到一个背景彩蛋。你看到安吉拉·马丁（Angela Martin）那自信张扬的波浪马尾辫了吗？没有。
A wavy pony. Yeah. I clocked it right away because wavy ponytail means one thing. It means we had been to a fancy party and this is day two hair for me. I showed up at work with great hair that had been blown out and styled the night before. And that's when Kim Ferry, who did my hair, would usually put it in a cute pony. Oh. And we would have to match the wave every day that I worked after that.
A wavy pony. Yeah. I clocked it right away because wavy ponytail means one thing. It means we had been to a fancy party and this is day two hair for me. I showed up at work with great hair that had been blown out and styled the night before. And that's when Kim Ferry, who did my hair, would usually put it in a cute pony. Oh. And we would have to match the wave every day that I worked after that.|||波浪马尾。是的。我一眼就认出来了，因为波浪马尾意味着一件事。这意味着我们去参加过一个豪华派对，这对我来说是做完发型的第二天。我顶着前一晚吹过并做过造型的漂亮头发去上班。通常在这个时候，负责我发型的金·费里（Kim Ferry）会把它扎成一个可爱的马尾。哦。在那之后我上班的每一天，我们都得保持这种波浪发型。
Sassy ponytail led me to my digital clutter. And lady, we filmed this episode in September of 2009 around the time of the Emmys. Oh. And I also wrote that my parents were in town for the Emmys. This is the year my dad went with me. Yeah. So I took them to everything I could get us invited to because I really wanted them to fill the whole experience of like going to the Emmys and the parties.
Sassy ponytail led me to my digital clutter. And lady, we filmed this episode in September of 2009 around the time of the Emmys. Oh. And I also wrote that my parents were in town for the Emmys. This is the year my dad went with me. Yeah. So I took them to everything I could get us invited to because I really wanted them to fill the whole experience of like going to the Emmys and the parties.|||这个自信张扬的马尾辫把我引向了我的数码杂物环节。女士，我们是在2009年9月艾美奖前后拍摄这一集的。哦。我还写道，我的父母为了艾美奖来到了城里。这是我父亲陪我去的那一年。是的。所以我带他们去了一切我能弄到邀请函的活动，因为我真的希望他们能充分体验参加艾美奖和派对的整个经历。
So yeah, I had sassy ponytail left over hair. Well that is amazing. And Angela, look at that. Your digital clutter. It made it into this episode after all. I snuck in. Well done. Thank you.
So yeah, I had sassy ponytail left over hair. Well that is amazing. And Angela, look at that. Your digital clutter. It made it into this episode after all. I snuck in. Well done. Thank you.|||所以，是的，我留着那个马尾辫的发型残余。这太神奇了。安吉拉，你看。你的数码杂物。它最终还是进入了这一集。我偷偷混进去了。干得好。谢谢。
Well, I wanted to point something out in the background of this as well. This is at three minutes 13 seconds. The watercolor on the wall. It has been replaced with a photo of a golf course that says failure is not an option. Yeah. It has been replaced with an inspirational poster. Although nothing's more inspiring than Pam's watercolor. It's hope in a frame, Jenna.
Well, I wanted to point something out in the background of this as well. This is at three minutes 13 seconds. The watercolor on the wall. It has been replaced with a photo of a golf course that says failure is not an option. Yeah. It has been replaced with an inspirational poster. Although nothing's more inspiring than Pam's watercolor. It's hope in a frame, Jenna.|||嗯，我还想指出这其中背景里的一个细节。在3分13秒处。墙上的水彩画。它被换成了一张写着“失败不是选项”（failure is not an option）的高尔夫球场照片。是的。它被换成了一张励志海报。尽管没有什么比帕姆的水彩画更鼓舞人心了。那是装在框里的希望，珍娜。
It is. I know. It's going to be back. It'll come back. Don't worry. It's coming back. Pam and Andy are now chatting with the receptionist. I watched the scene.
It is. I know. It's going to be back. It'll come back. Don't worry. It's coming back. Pam and Andy are now chatting with the receptionist. I watched the scene.|||确实如此。我知道。它会回来的。它会回来的。别担心。它会回来的。帕姆和安迪现在正在和前台接待员聊天。我看过这一场戏。
I rewound it because I laughed so hard. I feel like this is something I say when I'm in my mom mode. It's like someone's got a case of the definitely. Oh my gosh, Pam is so mortified when the receptionist thinks she's a couple with Andy and she does that thing where she overcompensates, where she's like, no, no, no, no, no, definitely not definitely not no, no, no, no, no, no. Yeah. She keeps repeating it.
I rewound it because I laughed so hard. I feel like this is something I say when I'm in my mom mode. It's like someone's got a case of the definitely. Oh my gosh, Pam is so mortified when the receptionist thinks she's a couple with Andy and she does that thing where she overcompensates, where she's like, no, no, no, no, no, definitely not definitely not no, no, no, no, no, no. Yeah. She keeps repeating it.|||我倒回去看了一遍，因为我笑得太厉害了。我觉得这就像是我进入母亲模式时会说的话。就好像某人得了“绝对症”一样。噢天哪，当接待员认为她和安迪是一对时，帕姆感到非常尴尬，她做出了那种矫枉过正的反应，她就像是：“不，不，不，不，不，绝对不是，绝对不是，不，不，不，不，不，不。”是的。她一直在重复。
The receptionist was played by Jennifer Hasty. She's been in tons of stuff. She's been on Bosch, Better Call Saul, Transparent and True Blood, and Angela, we had the hardest time getting through this scene. It was really difficult because they wanted me to really go on too long, like way too long before Andy says somebody has a case of the definitely. The direction was like keep hearing this idea in your head, like re-realize it over and over again.
The receptionist was played by Jennifer Hasty. She's been in tons of stuff. She's been on Bosch, Better Call Saul, Transparent and True Blood, and Angela, we had the hardest time getting through this scene. It was really difficult because they wanted me to really go on too long, like way too long before Andy says somebody has a case of the definitely. The direction was like keep hearing this idea in your head, like re-realize it over and over again.|||接待员由詹妮弗·海斯蒂（Jennifer Hasty）饰演。她演过很多作品。她出演过《博世》（Bosch）、《绝命律师》（Better Call Saul）、《透明家庭》（Transparent）和《真爱如血》（True Blood）。安吉拉，我们拍这场戏时简直难得要死。这真的很难，因为他们想让我说得太久、太夸张了，在安吉拉说“某人得了绝对症”之前，要拖很长时间。导演的指导就像是：在脑子里不断听到这个想法，就像是一遍又一遍地重新意识到这一点。
And then I do it like three times where I'm like, no, definitely not. Oh, no, no, no, definitely not. No, no, no, no, no. It's as if she keeps saying it, but she's not saying it. That was the direction was to keep hearing it and responding. Well, it was really funny. I loved it. Well, Warren and Halstead said that this plot was loosely based on a story that they heard
And then I do it like three times where I'm like, no, definitely not. Oh, no, no, no, definitely not. No, no, no, no, no. It's as if she keeps saying it, but she's not saying it. That was the direction was to keep hearing it and responding. Well, it was really funny. I loved it. Well, Warren and Halstead said that this plot was loosely based on a story that they heard|||然后我大概做了三次，就像是：“不，绝对不是。哦，不，不，不，绝对不是。不，不，不，不，不。”就好像她一直在说，但又没有在说。指导就是要求不断听到它并做出反应。嗯，真的很好笑。我很喜欢。嗯，沃伦和霍尔斯特德说，这个情节大致取材于他们听过的一个故事，
in their real life, but they couldn't remember now who it was, but they said they had a female friend who was pregnant and she went to Ikea with a male friend, not her husband, and everyone kept referring to them as a couple. And they were just like, we get it. I mean, we're shopping for furniture together and I'm pregnant. Everyone just kept congratulating them. And so they remembered that and that's kind of the inspiration for this plotline. And I'm sure in that moment, at first you're like, oh, actually we're not related.
in their real life, but they couldn't remember now who it was, but they said they had a female female friend who was pregnant and she went to Ikea with a male friend, not her husband, and everyone kept referring to them as a couple. And they were just like, we get it. I mean, we're shopping for furniture together and I'm pregnant. Everyone just kept congratulating them. And so they remembered that and that's kind of the inspiration for this plotline. And I'm sure in that moment, at first you're like, oh, actually we're not related.|||发生在他们的现实生活中，但他们现在记不清是谁了，不过他们说他们有一个怀孕的女性朋友，她和一个男性朋友（不是她丈夫）一起去了宜家，结果每个人都一直把他们当成是一对情侣。他们当时就想，我们懂了。我的意思是，我们一起买家具，而且我还怀着孕。每个人都在不断地祝贺他们。所以他们记住了这件事，这就是这个情节的灵感来源。我敢肯定在那一刻，一开始你可能会说：“哦，其实我们没有关系。”
Oh, actually we're not a couple. Oh, yeah, yeah. At some point you're like, yeah, sure, we just, because it's just easier to go with it. You're like, you need to buy what we're buying. Yeah, sure. We're going to get out of there. Back at the office, Erin gets an interesting phone call.
Oh, actually we're not a couple. Oh, yeah, yeah. At some point you're like, yeah, sure, we just, because it's just easier to go with it. You're like, you need to buy what we're buying. Yeah, sure. We're going to get out of there. Back at the office, Erin gets an interesting phone call.|||“哦，其实我们不是情侣。”“哦，对，对。”到某个时刻你会觉得：“好吧，当然，我们只是……”因为顺着他们的话说会更容易。你会觉得：你得买我们正在买的东西。是的，当然。我们得离开那儿了。回到办公室，埃林接到了一通有趣的电话。
She does. It's from the custodian at Raskin Design. Apparently they found Michael's keys in the koi pond. She announces this out loud and the bullpen is an instant buzz. The koi pond, your key's in the koi pond. Everyone is very curious. I love the cut to the next moment where Michael's phone rings and then we pull out and reveal everyone hovering around reception and Erin just being like, Michael, people have a lot
She does. It's from the custodian at Raskin Design. Apparently they found Michael's keys in the koi pond. She announces this out loud and the bullpen is an instant buzz. The koi pond, your key's in the koi pond. Everyone is very curious. I love the cut to the next moment where Michael's phone rings and then we pull out and reveal everyone hovering around reception and Erin just being like, Michael, people have a lot|||确实如此。是拉askin设计公司的清洁工打来的。显然他们在锦鲤池里找到了迈克尔的钥匙。她大声宣布了这件事，开放式办公区瞬间沸腾了。锦鲤池，你的钥匙在锦鲤池里。每个人都很好奇。我非常喜欢切到下一个镜头的那个瞬间，迈克尔的电话响了，然后镜头拉远，展现出每个人都围在前台周围，而埃林则是一副：“迈克尔，大家有很多
of questions. These scenes were always so much fun to film because it's just a big group clump and we got to have like our dialogue sort of rapid fire back and forth. I have such fond memories of doing scenes like that. Well, the truth is going to come out. Michael tries to say, yes, he fell in a koi pond, but how do they know that he wasn't trying to save a child? And Angela's like, so a child fell in the koi pond?
of questions. These scenes were always so much fun to film because it's just a big group clump and we got to have like our dialogue sort of rapid fire back and forth. I have such fond memories of doing scenes like that. Well, the truth is coming out. Michael tries to say, yes, he fell in a koi pond, but how do they know that he wasn't trying to save a child? And Angela's like, so a child fell in the koi pond?|||问题要问”的样子。拍摄这些场景总是非常有趣，因为大家聚成了一大团，我们的台词就像机关枪一样快节奏地来回对答。我对拍摄这样的场景有着非常美好的回忆。嗯，真相要大白了。迈克尔试图辩解说，是的，他掉进了锦鲤池，但他们怎么知道他不是在试图救一个孩子呢？而安吉拉则说：“所以有个小孩掉进锦鲤池里了？”
And Michael's like, not yet. Not yet. It's amazing. Jim has a great talking head. He says it wasn't so much how Michael fell in, but it was how long it took him to get out. You know, that's got to be true. You know, like getting out of that koi pond for Warren.
And Michael's like, not yet. Not yet. It's amazing. Jim has a great talking head. He says it wasn't so much how Michael fell in, but it was how long it took him to get out. You know, that's got to be true. You know, like getting out of that koi pond for Warren.|||迈克尔说：“还没呢。还没。”这太绝了。吉姆有一个很棒的单人采访镜头。他说，重点与其说是迈克尔是怎么掉进去的，不如说是他花了多长时间才爬出来。你知道的，这绝对是真的。你知道的，就像沃伦从那个锦鲤池里爬出来一样。
I thought the same thing. Realizing what had happened and all the people looking over the railing at him. Oh my gosh. Well it's time for Pam and Andy to do their big pitch, right? They've got their sales pitch. Yes, they're talking to Tim Dockery and he's really impressed. He's especially impressed, you know, because he's running a family business and they're clearly a family business.
I thought the same thing. Realizing what had happened and all the people looking over the railing at him. Oh my gosh. Well it's time for Pam and Andy to do their big pitch, right? They've got their sales pitch. Yes, they're talking to Tim Dockery and he's really impressed. He's especially impressed, you know, because he's running a family business and they're clearly a family business.|||我也是这么想的。意识到发生了什么，所有人都在栏杆上看着他。噢天哪。好吧，现在是帕姆和安迪做重大推介的时候了，对吧？他们有他们的销售推介。是的，他们正在跟蒂姆·多克里（Tim Dockery）交谈，他对他们印象深刻。他特别印象深刻，你知道的，因为他经营着一家家族企业，而他们俩显然是一家家族企业。
Pam and Andy have to do the, oh no, we're not. We're actually not a couple. No, no. But then Andy goes on and on. Well it's payback time. It's payback time for the lady who had a case of the definitely's. I guess so. And he says, oh yeah, no, I'm not with her.
Pam and Andy have to do the, oh no, we're not. We're actually not a couple. No, no. But then Andy goes on and on. Well it's payback time. It's payback time for the lady who had a case of the definitely's. I guess so. And he says, oh yeah, no, I'm not with her.|||帕姆和安迪不得不解释：“哦不，我们不是。我们其实不是情侣。不，不。”但接着安吉拉……不对，是安迪喋喋不休地说个不停。好吧，复仇的时刻到了。对于那个得了“绝对症”的女士来说，复仇的时刻到了。我想是的。然后他说：“哦，对，不，我和她不是一对。”
I only date face models on a scale from one to Giselle, like my girlfriend's a nine. Pam's just a surrogate, you know, because we don't need her to look good. I loved that. Apparently like we're not a couple, but that is his baby. Oh yeah. He's going to claim the baby. Yeah. All right.
I only date face models on a scale from one to Giselle, like my girlfriend's a nine. Pam's just a surrogate, you know, because we don't need her to look good. I loved that. Apparently like we're not a couple, but that is his baby. Oh yeah. He's going to claim the baby. Yeah. All right.|||“我约会的对象都是面部模特，从一到吉赛尔（Giselle）的标准来看，比如我女朋友是个九分。帕姆只是个代孕，你知道的，因为我们不需要她长得好看。”我太喜欢这个了。显然就像是我们不是情侣，但那是他的孩子。哦，是的。他要认领这个孩子。是的。好吧。
I have two things to point out in the scene. Number one is my guest star alert, Tom Yee played Tim Dockery. According to his bio, he has lived in four countries on three continents. Impressive. Yeah. And he has been on the West Wing, Arrested Development, Dr. Ken, Community, and Monk. Monk connection. We got another one of those.
It's been a while. Yeah. And then at three minutes, 55 seconds, I wanted to point out Pam's baby bump. Okay. It is much more pronounced in this episode compared to last episode. And that is because I am wearing bump B. You've gone up a size in the bump. I've gone up a bump. Alicia, our costume designer, made a document that she called the belly tracker.
And she tracked from the first time we heard of Pam's pregnancy news all the way to when she would give birth and she painstakingly mapped out each time we needed to go up in a belly. And this was our first belly bump. We went up to bump B. They became increasingly less comfortable. And I became increasingly more miserable. I have something to share about that later that you don't know, but I'm waiting. I'm waiting.
Oh my gosh. Well, Angela, I look forward to whatever this piece of information is that you will be giving me later. Yeah. I think it's going to make you laugh. Okay. Before we leave this scene, Jenna, I wanted to share with you guys that the name Tim Dockery actually came from Warren's best friend from college, who's Martin Dockery.
Hi, Martin. But I guess the name Martin didn't clear. Tim is Martin's brother. So there you go, Tim Dockery. It was always fun when our writers got to put a friend's name or a relative's name in an episode. The next scene has a joke in it that made me laugh so hard. Am I a dork?
Michael asked Aaron for one of those clips that hold paper together and Aaron says staples. Staples? Yeah. I loved it. I did too. Aaron tells Michael that David Wallace called to say that he heard Michael made a big splash at the meeting, but then she immediately backtracks because that didn't really happen and she feels bad and everybody put her up to it.
She says Kevin and Meredith put me up to it and then Kevin leans through the file cabinet and says, I will kill you. But yes, that line is inspired from the real life event when Warren's agent called and said, I heard you made a big splash. We had a fan question from Ella B in Ontario at seven minutes, 13 seconds. You can see a picture of a fish tank on Pam's computer, which is Jim's old desk. And then a couple seconds later, you can see the same screensaver on Andy's computer. Was this a nod to the Koi pond?
It was. And in fact, if you watch Michael walk through the bullpen, he clocks Andy's computer. And obviously, Pam and Andy don't know anything about the falling in the Koi pond. They are not at the office to change their screens. So I guess you have to imagine that someone in the office is doing this. Well, in the deleted scenes, it's clear that Kevin is having maybe the most fun with this. I don't know if it's Kevin, usually the one that falls or trips or something happens and now someone else has had a big fall.
But in the deleted scenes as Michael walks through the bullpen, Kevin makes this noise with each step. Like water, like squishy water in your shoes and Michael's like, stop it. So someone in the office was really having fun. Well Michael is going to hold a sensitivity training meeting in the conference room. Yeah. And we're going to make a list. We're going to make a list of things that we can no longer talk about.
No teasing. He's called a do not mock list. Michael writes the first one, Koi pond, and he also admits he's fallen into the fountain at the Steamtown Mall as well. So he writes Koi pond and fountain. We had a fan catch from Victoria S. in Orlando, Florida. When Michael says he's fallen into a fountain at the Steamtown Mall, I don't think there's actually a fountain there.
I was born and raised in Northeast Pennsylvania. I have been to the Steamtown Mall and I don't recall seeing one there. Well, Victoria, our producer, Cassie, wanted to find out. Cassie, tell us what do you know about the fountain at Steamtown Mall? Do you have a deep dive, Cassie? Yes. I have a little deep dive of me trying to figure out if there was some fountain at the Steamtown Mall.
I called and emailed and I could not get through and I think they probably were like super weirded out by me just saying, like, hi, I just want to know if there's a fountain here. So they weren't responding to me. And I went on Google, I tried to look at pictures. I watched old news clips of people doing segments at the mall and I could not find a fountain. I was about to give up and I was like, you know what, I'm going to reach out to the Office Ladies Facebook fan page because people post pictures of them in Scranton. So I reached out to Nikki who moderates it and then she was like, I'm on it and like
a couple hours later she got back to me and was like, so I couldn't find any pictures. I called the Steamtown Mall, got a hold of someone. They were very weirded out by her asking if there's a fountain there. Why are all these people calling and asking if there's a fountain? So they were like, well, we'll get your name and phone number and someone will contact you. And then an hour later she just got a text message from them saying, no, we don't. All right, I love this story so much. I love that both of you women were calling the Steamtown Mall asking if there's a fountain
and the people are like, what do these ladies want to do in a fountain? Why are they looking for a fountain so badly? I want to picture the person answering the phone like later that day, maybe they're on their break, having a snack, they're with other co-workers and they're like, you guys getting calls like with people asking if we have a fountain? Like what the hell? Thank you, Cassie. But Victoria, you are right.
There is no fountain in the Steamtown Mall. Yes. Okay. Well, Angela, I have a mystery I want to solve from this scene and I'm calling it Ryan Has Glasses. Remember last episode, he was wearing his Trilby hat? Yeah. Yes.
Well, now he's holding a pair of glasses. They never go on his face. After I saw this, I watched the whole episode waiting for those glasses to go on his face. But he's just gesturing with them. He's just got a pair of fake glasses. I don't know what he's going through. Ryan and the accessories. Yeah.
He's wanting to feel dignified or something. I guess so. Michael wants other people to shout out things they don't want to be teased about. And Dwight volunteers. He says, my nose is too small. And then he has a talking head where he says, the geometric proportions of my face are perfect in every way, but one, my nose is too small. I mean, it works.
I can still smell things. I just have to be a lot closer than most people. And then rain as Dwight does this little like sniffy sniff. It's really cute. Actually, I thought it was cute. We got so much mail about this, Angela. People really wanted to know if rain participated in this, the writing of this, or if it was a total surprise to him when he got the script.
Well, here's what Halstead said. He said they asked rain if there was anything about him that people made fun of or that he was ever sensitive about growing up. And rain said, okay, my nose being small. And it actually worked as a really funny bit. Obviously rain is fine with his nose now, you know? Yes. But Halstead said they liked to reach out to the actors to get things that way.
It's better coming from the actor than the writer making something up that maybe I guess could hurt your feelings, right? Yeah. No, they were always really good about that. That's very funny. As the scene goes on, other people participate. And I zoomed in on the dry erase board at the end to see what Michael had written on the board under each person's name.
The Do Not Mock list has Michael, Koi Pond and Fountain, Dwight, Nose Too Small, Aaron, Orphan, Kevin, Huge Gut, Angela, Shrimpy, Meredith, Sex with the Terrorist. Shrimpy? Shrimpy? So I was like, what? So I went to the script. Shrimpy is not in the script. It says for Angela, Michael writes, tiny bitch, and I think Steve in the moment just wrote
Shrimpy. Well, there is a deleted scene for Aaron explaining why they wrote Orphan. That's right. Leaving the conference room, we are back with Pam and Andy. They are at their next sales call. They are with Keena Gifford, played by Amy Reed. Well, Angela, we know Amy Reed very well. I thought perhaps you'd like to give us the guest star breakdown on this one.
Oh, I would love to. So Amy Reed, we knew her at this time as Amy Weaver. And she is just a dear friend of mine. And I've known her a long time. We met working at iOS. I think our bonding moment was the song Jolene came on. And she's from Oklahoma, and my family's from Texas and Louisiana. And we both, without missing a beat, just started going, Jolene, Jolene, Jolene, Jolene!
In our southern accents. I just love her so much. She is a hilarious actress and phenomenal writer. She's still one of my dearest friends to this day. And I reached out to Amy and asked her if she could share her memories of being on the set of the office. And here's what she had to share. First of all, she said her scenes were only with Jenna and Ed in this super small abandoned
office building. There wasn't a huge cast or crew, so she really got to hang out, which is fun. She said one of the things she remembers is that Jenna was wearing a really huge baby bump. And it was making her go to the bathroom. And she went to the bathroom one time right before they called them back to set. And some very sweet, but maybe a little too eager, production assistant, was knocking nonstop on the door while poor Jenna was trying to get the belly back on.
Amy said, I only really appreciated how hot and heavy those suckers are many years later on a shoot where I had to be fake pregnant. She said she would like everyone to know even fake pregnant women should not be rushed in the bathroom. That's the lesson here. I knew you'd be happy. I know you're applauding. I am slow clapping that, Amy.
Thank you. I feel so validated. Let me explain what you have on. It's not just a belly. So I was wearing, for a reason I don't know, tights. Yeah. So I've got underwear tights. And on top of that, you have on like what's like almost a wetsuit with boy shorts.
And that goes all the way up over your bra. It's like a whole contraption. And then from there, they can slide in different sized bellies. Then I had all my clothes on top of that. And I also had on a microphone and a microphone pack with a wire taped to you. Yes. So to go to the bathroom, I had to dismantle all of that. It was a good 10 minutes just to get undressed.
Then I had to pee. Then I had to put it all on again. It was like 20 minutes. If I said I need to go to the bathroom, that was a 20 minute break because it was really difficult and frustrating and no one seemed to get it. And I really, like I asked Alicia, I was like, Alicia, is it worth like gathering the production team together and sort of like taking them through all the layers because they expect me to pee in the same amount of time that I always pee, but I'm wearing so many more
elements and maybe there's like a workshop we could do to show them. Yes. And I actually think, Angela, correct me if I'm wrong. Wasn't there a day where Kelly Cantley, our first AD, put it on and wore it? Yes, because you were like, someone else needs to experience this. Please. I'm begging you. And so she put it on.
You know, years later, I would have to wear the same thing. And I feel like you paved the way with our crew about what to expect. I know. But you know what? It was a tough road. It was a tough paving. Well, after all these years, that's the first thing Amy remembered to share with me. Amy, thank you.
Thank you. I'm so touched. She went on to say Jenna and Ed and I were jammed into a tiny office and the director, Reggie and the crew were outside the door on the other side. And at some point during downtime between takes, Jen and I got really chatty with each other. And I guess we were kind of leaving Ed out of the conversation with very little room to jump in.
And he finally just interrupted and said, do you two know each other? Because you had met Amy through me and we had become all a group of friends. Yeah. Yeah. The last thing Amy shared was this. One random thing that made a huge impression on me that day was when Jenna invited me to her trailer for lunch. As we sat there chatting, it somehow came up about the beginning of you and hers friendship.
Jenna shared about the transition you guys had by being on the cast of the office, how you two really bonded over going from inconsistent acting careers to suddenly being in the limelight and the impact and weight of being on the office and the adjustment to that and how you two were together through all of it, through that transition, you balanced earnest humility and the thrill of being on the number one comedy. Wow. Now I'm like crying. I thought that was wonderful.
I know. Yeah. I mean, that was true. I can't imagine having to have done that without you, Angela. Aw, lady. It was overwhelming. It was all of your professional dreams coming true, but all the ways that you don't think that that is going to impact your life in weird ways, your face on television every week.
What that does, how it changes different relationships or friendships, how your time is not your own when you are on a television show, the long hours, but then all of the additional promotional work that takes up your weekends and how you can't go to things anymore and to have someone to go through that with and navigate that with and you're so excited, but then the midwesterner in me would always feel like very shy about it and I think we had that in common. I mean, she really nailed it. I know. I thought what great observations from her day on set.
Yeah. Well, you know, I feel the same way, lady. Oh, my gosh. How would I gotten through, you know, the last 18 years, oh, my word, without your friendship. Oh, my gosh, 18. I have one last fun tidbit about this scene. Warren reminded me of it and I went and looked for it immediately. There is a photo of our daughter, Isabelle, in a frame just over Amy's shoulder.
If you go to 11 minutes, 35 seconds, you can see Isabelle in the little silver frame. She's smiling so big. She's in her car seat. I love that Phil Shea did that for us. It just, oh, my gosh, warmed my heart so much. I saw it too. Oh, oh, and one last thing. I know I've had a lot to say about this scene.
So Miss Gifford and Andy bond over this birthing teacher named Miss Janet. Well, Janet is my sister's name. Hmm. That's so sweet. So there you go, that's everything that I had for that scene. Well, I think we should take a break. And when we come back, we're going to talk about how you eat like a squirrel, Angela. Okay, great.
We are back and we are still in the conference room. People are still talking about the things that bother them and Angela, you do not like it when people say you eat like a squirrel. You don't care for that. I don't care for that. And also I'm afraid someone's going to throw me around like a football because I'm so petite. Erin is going to interrupt this meeting and let Michael know that someone has called to
inform them that one of the Koi died and they want him to pay for it. It's going to be $300. Aren't Koi like crazy expensive? Yeah, they are. And Halstead shared that they had pitched around in the writer's room a kind of extension of this storyline because they found out that some Koi can like cost as much as $2,000. So at one point, the Koi that Michael killed was going to be worth $2,000 and that Michael was going to pay for it.
He was going to get it because he was going to want to see a $2,000 fish and then back at the office, he was going to cook it in the toaster oven and eat it. No. Yes, this was the pitch. But then ultimately Michael was going to chicken out and he was just going to throw it away. And Halstead said by the time they got to the end of this pitch, they were like, you know what? It's disturbing.
But how about the Koi is just $300 and there's no eating of the Koi or throwing it away? Yes. And Halstead said, I'm very happy we changed that. Well you know, Michael wouldn't have thrown it away. If he didn't eat it, he would have had a proper burial for it. That's most likely, yes. And there would have been a Koi funeral. Yes.
And then maybe Creed would have digged it up and eaten it. Of course. I did love when Creed was like, oh man, you're paying way too much for worms. Who's your worm guy? Who's your worm guy? So funny. Put that on a shirt. Jim is going to get Michael aside and say, I have a strategy.
I think maybe you should make fun of yourself for falling into the Koi pond. Yeah. And that will diffuse everyone else, right? Yeah. And you'll be able to tell jokes because you've covered it. So Michael's going to try it. He's like, all right, I'll try it. And at first, it goes well.
And then it doesn't. He goes too far. He goes too far and he knows he's going too far. This was such a brilliant performance. It's like that thing when you're like talking to someone and you know that moment you went past where you should have stopped. And in your own brain, you're like, stop, stop, but you can't. Yes.
And he just keeps talking. He keeps saying embarrassing things about his life that aren't even about the Koi pond. Well Warren shared with us that this was one of his favorite comedy bits. And he said when Michael goes too far with it, they had even more pitch, Jenna. They had even more jokes in the pipeline here. He said he and Halstead loved writing this runner. Here were some that didn't make it in the show. Are you ready?
I'm ready. Okay. I can't listen to talk radio when I drive because I get scared that someone else is in the car. Okay. Then there was another one where Michael locks himself in a dog cage at Kmart. No one could get him out. He was stuck and they had to call the fire department.
Okay. Then there was a take when Michael goes so far and cuts so deep at himself that he makes himself cry. And Warren said Steve's performance was so phenomenal. It was his favorite take. He fought really hard, but too many people disagreed. They said it was too depressing and Warren lost the battle. So it ends with the, wow, this was definitely one of those scenes where we would go to the
candy bag. They would always have extra stuff for scenes like this. And I know we say this a lot, you guys, but Steve is so amazing because he could dial it up or dial it down or cry or just, he could do anything. He was so impressive. I would lose myself. I've said this before. I'd be like, oh crap.
I'm supposed to be reacting as Angela Martin and instead I was just there like, oh my gosh, Steve is crushing it. I wish I could have been there. I would have loved to have watched this. That was maybe one of the things that was so fun about rewatching this episode was that I was really watching this as a fan because I wasn't there. So I don't have memories of what else went on or what got cut. I'm just watching it.
It's great. Same. I got so tickled when Andy says, it looks like someone's got a case of the definitely because I wasn't there when you guys did that. Yeah. Well, now Angela, I've got a fan question for you because you are in the break room and you are eating a nut. Heather C from Leeds in the UK said, Angela, one of my favorite Angela moments ever is
the bit where you eat like a squirrel in the break room. So the part where you wrap your packaging back up cracks me up so much. How did you come up with this bit exactly? Did you perhaps watch a lot of videos of squirrels eating? Heather, that's hilarious. Well, thank you for appreciating my squirrel eating performance. You know, honestly, I didn't watch any videos. I just, you know, I've seen a squirrel eat and I use my own personal life observation.
And just so you know, the stage direction in the script for the scene was Meredith, Kevin, Angela and Oscar sit at tables. Angela gnaws at an almond holding it with two hands like a squirrel. So I knew I had to hold it with two hands just the way I'm doing it. And then I just ate it the way I thought a squirrel would eat it. And then in the script, it goes on to say she puts the rest of her almond back into saran wrap. So that was in the script, but how I folded it and did it, you know, it was just me sort
of playing in the moment. I had so much fun doing that and we kept laughing like Brian and Oscar, we all kept cracking up. Well, as your BFF, I will go on record to say that you do not actually eat like that. We all know you bite right into the string cheese. Oh yeah. I'm not holding it with two hands, gnawing at it. I'm going to chomp at it.
You're not stringing it or anything. You're just eating it. But you do often wrap up the second half of whatever you haven't eaten. This is true. That is true. This is true. If you open my fridge right now, there's like four grapes wrapped up in a little piece of tinfoil.
You're going to eat those later? I will. So listen, back in the meeting with Pam and Andy, Andy is really gets a little out of control. He's like smothering Pam's belly with his face. So they've just finally decided to lean into it. Yeah, fine. We're a couple.
This is our baby to try to make the sale. But we learn a lot about Andy in this moment. We do. And afterwards, Pam says, you know, that was great, but maybe you took it a little far and he's like, yeah, yeah, it was maybe the belly kissing was a little much. And he reveals a couple of things. Then he reveals that it was nice for him to pretend for a minute that he was part of a couple with a baby on the way.
Oh, that broke my heart. I know. And then he also reveals that maybe he has a little crush on Aaron. Hmm. Hmm. Well, guess what? Meredith's roommate is friends with the night janitor at the office building where Michael fell and she's got a copy of the security footage.
Yes, she does. Everyone is going to gather around Meredith's computer and we are going to see Michael fall into the Koi pond. We got so many fan questions about the fall into the Koi pond. And we're going to do our best to break it down for you. Starting with Callie B from Rogers, Arkansas, who asked, where was the security footage of Steve falling into the pond filmed? She told us that we shot the Koi pond just down the street from our studios.
They were a neon sign manufacturing business called Knights of Neon. This business has operated for over 30 years and they make custom neon signs for commercial use. I really hope their logo is like a knight in like metal armor holding up like a shield. Knights of Neon. Oh, well, it's spelled N-I-G-H-T-S of neon. I'm kidding, I'm kidding. This company, Knights of Neon, had a really big empty warehouse and that's why we picked
it. We rented it out for a whole week and Michael Gallenberg and his construction coordinator, Tim James, they started by laying down like a waterproof liner over the entire floor of the warehouse. Then they built a Koi pond on top of it that held a thousand gallons of filtered water and then they made the walkways on top of it. They also then set up two cameras. Reggie really wanted like this motorized surveillance camera that would sort of sweep the lobby
back and forth. And so Matt Stone created this effect by using a tripod with a fluid head mounted on top of a tall ladder. So they made this fakey, sweepy security camera. I guess this sweeping shot is best seen in the deleted scenes around four minutes, nine seconds. Oh, yeah. Go to the deleted scenes for this episode.
It's the last one. It's the whole entire footage of Michael falling in and when I watched it, I was like, oh, wow. I didn't realize how long Steve was in the water. I mean, they really went for it. Well, I guess we added another stationary non-moving B camera that was angled a little bit more at the front. Derek Carver was our B camera operator that day. And the footage that you end up seeing on this tape that everyone's watching is that
B camera footage, the still footage. All right. Next question. This one comes from Braylon M. in Seattle, Washington. Were there actually koi in the pond that Michael falls in? Yes. Yes. Randy told us that we went with our usual animal training company, which was Bob Dunn's
animal rentals in Silmar, California. They do it all, clearly. They do. The head trainer there is Denise Sanders, but we had to also employ a special koi wrangler named Mike Long. What was Kelly Cantley thinking? She's had a fruit fly wrangler. She's had a koi wrangler.
Several cat wranglers. Fascinating. They filled up the koi pond with water several days in advance because they had to let the chlorine evaporate from the water. They did a careful pH balance, all of that. Randy said the koi were very expensive. Before they put the koi into the pond, they did a test with some goldfish just to make sure.
The goldfish, they were like, when the king has a tester, eat the food first. Those little goldfish, they lived. Well, thank God they lived. The koi went in. He said that we used 28 koi that were up to two feet long. They're very big. And that the total cost for the fish, the holding tanks, the pumps, the filters, and all the labor was $12,000.
Wow. That's a pricey koi pond. Well, when we started filming, Halstead shared that when they put the koi in the pond, they immediately all swam under the steps that went over the middle of the koi pond. And I guess they were in a new environment, and so they kind of go and hide. They check it out, and it takes them a bit to get comfortable and then to swim out from their hiding place. The koi wrangler told Halstead and Warren that they had to wait for the koi to settle
and come out before they could do the first take. These guys were just standing there waiting for the koi. Yeah, so someone probably made an announcement, guys, we're going to take five and let the koi get ready waiting on the koi. I've got another fan question now from Nina D in Washington. How many takes did you do of Michael falling into the pond? Randy said they really hoped the answer would be one, but the answer is two. Uh-oh.
I think we should mention that Steve did not have a stunt double, Steve actually fell into the pond. That is very clear if you go to deleted scenes. When he got out from doing it the first time, they went over and they checked that sweeping camera that they had set up. To look like security footage? It had missed all of the action. It swept past him and then he fell and then it swept back.
It missed it all. So they had to ask Steve to dry off and do it again. Warren shared that he could tell Steve was bummed out because he had fallen into the koi pond and splashed about and now he was going to have to do it again and he said Steve asked out loud if anyone would believe this was even possible and Paul Lieberstein, Warren's brother who was there at the time, pointed at Warren and said, oh, it's possible. Oh, no. And I guess somehow up to this point, Steve was unaware that it had actually happened
to Warren and Warren said Steve just looked at him and said, wow. Warren said that that was very generous because he could tell clearly there were many thoughts running through Steve's brain, which he chose not to say. And he just said, wow, and then they all started laughing. And Warren said, he knows a lot of people have said this, but it is true that Steve truly was the nicest. Wow. Can you imagine Steve looking at you and going, wow.
Okay. All right. All right then. Well. Halstead shared that after Steve fell into the pond, it caused all the koi to hide again. So Steve dried off, but then they had to wait for them to come out again. Halstead also shared, he doesn't even think you can see any of the koi. Listen, when I watch the deleted scene, it's like black and white kind of security cam,
right? It's supposed to. I couldn't really see the koi. I don't know why I'm whispering that. I'm doing that thing my mom does, where you whisper bad news. Yeah. I didn't see the koi. Yeah.
Well, I guess on this second take, they did get it on the sweeping camera, but like I said, they didn't even end up using that part of the footage anyway. Now this all leads me to our final fan question about this from Logan Z and Columbus, Ohio. When everyone is watching the clip of Michael falling in on the computer, did you actually get to watch the video or are you guys just pretending? It was a little bit of a combo. So they had some of the footage of Steve falling in and they had it on a little monitor that they showed us.
嗯，我想在第二条拍摄时，他们确实拍到了全景镜头，但就像我说的，最后他们根本没用那段素材。现在，这一切引出了来自俄亥俄州哥伦布市的洛根·Z（Logan Z）关于此事的最后一个粉丝提问。当大家在电脑上观看迈克尔掉进去的片段时，你们是真的看到了视频，还是只是在假装？这其实有点像是结合两者的结果。当时他们有斯蒂夫掉进去的一些素材，并且在一个小监视器上放给我们看。
It actually wasn't on Meredith's computer, but they did show it to the cast before we started rolling so we could see what happened. And then we all gather around Meredith's desk and we just sort of faked it. Yes. Randy said that they burned it in to the computer screen with special effects, that came later. And I think some of that is because they hadn't quite decided exactly what they were going to use yet when you guys shot your scene. I guess we should probably explain that as they're watching this video, everyone notices
其实它并不在梅雷迪思的电脑上，但在我们开始拍摄前，他们确实把视频放给演员们看了，所以我们知道发生了什么。然后我们都聚在梅雷迪思的桌子旁，假装在看。是的。兰迪说他们是用特效把画面合成到电脑屏幕上的，那是后来才做的。我想部分原因是因为当你们拍这场戏时，他们还没完全决定好到底要用哪个片段。我想我们大概应该解释一下，当他们看这段视频时，每个人都注意到
that as Michael's falling in, Jim like leans back. I mean, hard. Completely. It's like he's stepping out of the way like, no, no, no, no, no, don't take me with you. He does not try to grab Michael. He does not try to stop it. And everyone is now piling on Jim. They're like, yeah, Jim, you could have caught Michael.
当迈克尔掉下去的时候，吉姆往后倾身了。我是说，倾得很厉害。完全是。就像他在闪躲一样，好像在说：不，不，不，不，不，别把我一起带下去。他没有试图去拉迈克尔。他没有试图阻止这一切。现在所有人都把矛头指向了吉姆。他们觉得：天哪，吉姆，你本可以抓住迈克尔的。
What the hell? We got a fan question from Kelly S. in Portland, Maine, who is wondering, like, was Jim really at fault for Michael falling in the Koi pond? You know, it's not like he bumped him. Kelly says, what was Jim supposed to do if he'd grabbed Michael? Maybe they would have both fallen in. Thoughts? Thoughts.
搞什么鬼？我们收到了来自缅因州波特兰市的凯利·S（Kelly S.）的粉丝提问，她想知道，吉姆对迈克尔掉进锦鲤池真的有责任吗？你知道的，他又不是故意撞他的。凯利说，如果吉姆抓住了迈克尔，他能怎么做？说不定他俩都掉下去了。大家怎么看？大家怎么看？
It's sort of an interesting character assessment of your personal character. It's like fight, flight, or freeze, right? So, so Michael's falling. Let's say you and I are walking over a Koi pond and you're next to me and you start to fall. I would hope my first instinct would be to grab for you. I mean, I do that with my kids. You know how that mom instinct kicks in, like you're at a soccer game and there's a ball
这有点像对你个人性格的一种有趣评估。就像是战斗、逃跑还是呆立，对吧？所以，迈克尔正在往下掉。假设你和我正走在一个锦鲤池旁边，你走在我旁边，然后你开始往下掉。我希望我的第一直觉是伸手去抓你。我是说，我对我的孩子就会这样。你知道那种母亲的本能是怎么被激发出来的，比如你在看一场足球比赛，有一个球
that goes crazy towards the stands and you grab your kid out of the way? I mean, it's just like a reflex. Lady, this just made me remember something that happened in our real life. So I'm just remembering this. I was in the kitchen and Lee walked in the kitchen and he was soaking wet. Just like this. Just like he's soaking wet. What happened?
朝着看台飞快地冲过来，然后你一把把孩子拉开？我的这就是一种条件反射。天哪，这让我想起了我们现实生活中发生的一件事。我想起来了。当时我在厨房里，李走进了厨房，他浑身湿透。就像这样。就像他浑身湿透了一样。发生什么事了？
I know. I know where this is going. What happened? And he was like, I fell in the swimming pool. I'm like, you fell in the swimming pool. How? So when our daughter was little, she used to like it when Lee would fake throw her in the swimming pool.
我知道。我知道这要说到哪儿去了。发生什么了？他说：我掉进游泳池里了。我说：你掉进游泳池里了？怎么会？原来在我们女儿小的时候，她以前挺喜欢让李假装把她扔进游泳池里的。
Sure, like swing her out over and then swing her back. Yes, swing her out over and then swing her back. And he was like, I was doing the thing where I swing her over the swimming pool. But I lost my balance and I fell in and I was like, is she okay? Did she fall in? He's like, she's fine. She's dry. Well, we have a security camera, Angela, and we went and we got the footage.
没错，就是把她荡出去，然后再拉回来。是的，把她荡出去，然后再拉回来。然后他说：我当时正在做把她荡过游泳池的那个动作。但是我失去了平衡，掉进去了，我就问：她没事吧？她掉进去了吗？他说：她没事。她身上是干的。嗯，我们有监控摄像头，安吉拉，然后我们去调了录像。
It is so funny. We still sometimes play it as a family. You can see him like fake swinging her over the pool. He's swinging her and then he's swinging her and then he swings her and you see him start to lose his balance. And through some, like you're saying, like in these moments, what is your character? What is your instinct? Through some like heroic feet, like the kind of thing you see football players do where
太搞笑了。我们有时还会作为家庭节目把它放出来看。你能看到他假装把她荡过水面。他把她荡过来，又荡过去，然后把她荡出去，接着你就能看到他开始失去平衡。通过某种，就像你说的，在这些时刻，你的性格是什么？你的直觉是什么？通过某种英雄般的壮举，就像你在美式橄榄球运动员身上看到的那种
they get both feet down. Yeah. Before they fall out of bounds, like you're like, how did they do it? He, while falling into the pool, whips our daughter around and places her gently on the side and then sort of falls backwards into the pool himself. It's really incredible. He saved her while falling himself. So I guess, I guess it's true, you know, in these moments, there's this instinctual part
双脚同时着地，在他们出界之前，你会想：他们是怎么做到的？他在掉进泳池的同时，把我们的女儿转了个身，轻轻地放在了池边，然后自己向后倒进了泳池里。这真的很不可思议。他在自己往下掉的同时救了她。所以我想，我想这是真的，你知道，在这些时刻，你身上总有一种本能的部分
of you that just kicks in. Yeah. So I would hope my instinct would be to grab you knowing I might fall in with you, but to at least try. Yeah. But Jim does just the opposite. He leans so far back. He's almost like, better you than me, you know?
会瞬间被激发。是的。所以我希望我的直觉会是去抓你，哪怕明知自己可能会跟你一起掉下去，但至少要试一下。是的。但吉姆做的恰恰相反。他往后倾得太厉害了。他几乎就像是在说：死道友不死贫道，你知道吗？
Yes. Yeah. Could he have helped him? Could he have at least reached out? Was he maybe just surprised and thrown off guard? Because that could happen. You could just be so surprised in the moment. I thought John did a great body acting job there.
是的。是的。他本可以帮他吗？他本可以至少伸一下手吗？也许他只是太震惊、太措手不及了？因为这完全有可能发生。你在当时就是会被吓得不知所措。我觉得约翰在那里肢体动作演得真好。
I thought he really did a good job. Well, the episode ends with Pam asking Aaron to fax something for her, and she sees it as an opportunity to bring up Andy. And she says, isn't he, you know, great? And Aaron's like, Andy is the coolest person I've ever met. Ooh, romance. I did catch a Post-it note at 20 minutes, 47 seconds. Guys, does it say call mom?
我觉得他真的演得很棒。嗯，剧集的结尾是帕姆请亚伦帮她发一封传真，她把这看作是提起安迪的一个机会。她说：他不是挺……你知道的，挺好的吗？然后亚伦说：安迪是我见过的最酷的人。哦，浪漫。我在20分47秒时确实抓拍到了一张便利贴。大家伙儿，上面写的是“给妈妈打电话”吗？
It says call mom and then something on the bottom I couldn't make out. That's weird. I know. Because Aaron has just shared she's an orphan. So what's the Post-it note with call mom? Do you think Ellie needed to call her mom? I don't know. Is it a Post-it note to herself?
上面写着“给妈妈打电话”，下面还有些字我辨认不出来。真奇怪。我知道。因为亚伦刚刚分享过她是个孤儿。那写着“给妈妈打电话”的便利贴是怎么回事？你觉得是艾莉需要给她妈妈打电话吗？我不知道。这是她留给自己的便签吗？
Maybe it was. I used to do that. Oh, I know. I saw your grocery list. Well, guys, that's Koi Pond. It is. And we have some shout outs, some big thank yous to go over. Yes.
也许是的。我以前经常那样做。哦，我懂。我还看过你的购物清单呢。好了，各位，这就是《锦鲤池》。确实是的。我们有一些鸣谢要表达，要对很多人表示深深的感谢。是的。
Thank you so much, Randy Cordray, for giving us the lowdown on how you built that Koi Pond and how that all worked. And thank you to Warren and Halstead for your amazing behind the scenes fax and for your audio clips breaking down the real life event. We wanted to let you know that Halstead is a producer on Central Park. It's an animated show and the second half of season two is going to premiere on Apple TV on March 4th. It is a fully animated musical starring Leslie Odom Jr., Katherine Hahn, Josh Gad, Titus
非常感谢兰迪·科德雷（Randy Cordray），跟我们详细讲述了你是如何建造那个锦鲤池以及这一切是如何运作的。也非常感谢沃伦（Warren）和霍尔斯特德（Halstead），感谢你们带来精彩的幕后传真故事，以及剖析现实生活中事件的音频片段。我们想让大家知道，霍尔斯特德是《中央公园》（Central Park）的制片人。这是一部动画剧集，第二季的后半部分将于3月4日在Apple TV上首播。这是一部全动画音乐剧，由小莱斯利·奥多姆（Leslie Odom Jr.）、凯瑟琳·哈恩（Kathryn Hahn）、乔什·加德（Josh Gad）、蒂图斯
Burgess, Emmy Raver-Lapman, Kristen Bell, Davide Diggs, and Stanley Tucci. And I think I have to say a personal thank you to Warren, who just humored his ex-wife texting him a whole bunch about this episode. And I'd also like to say a big thank you to our friend Amy Weaver, now Amy Reed. She has written a feature called Smokey Mountain Rain, which she is also set to direct. Go Amy. Go Amy. Guys, we love you.
伯格斯（Titus Burgess）、艾米·拉韦尔-兰普曼（Emmy Raver-Lapman）、克里斯汀·贝尔（Kristen Bell）、戴维德·迪格斯（Daveed Diggs）和斯坦利·图齐（Stanley Tucci）主演。我想我要特别感谢沃伦，他只是耐着性子回复了他前妻发来的一大堆关于这集的短信。我还想大大感谢我们的朋友艾米·韦弗（Amy Weaver），现在叫艾米·里德（Amy Reed）。她写了一部名为《斯莫基山雨》（Smokey Mountain Rain）的故事片，并且还将亲自执导。加油，艾米。加油，艾米。各位，我们爱你们。
We'll see you again next week. Yeah, because there's a double date with Jim and Pam and Michael and Pam's mom. Oh no, what could go wrong? We'll see you next week. See you then. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher.
我们下周再见。对，因为下周有吉姆、帕姆、迈克尔以及帕姆妈妈的四人约会。哦不，这会出什么乱子呢？我们下周见。回头见。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由Earwolf、珍娜·费舍（Jenna Fisher）和安吉拉·金斯利（Angela Kinsey）制作。我们的节目执行制片人是科迪·费舍（Cody Fisher）。
Our producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our sound engineer is Sam Kieffer. And our associate producer is Ainsley Bubicoe. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one month trial at Stitcher Premium, use code, OFFICE. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的制片人是卡西·杰金斯（Cassie Jerkins）。我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗（Sam Kieffer）。我们的副制片人是艾恩斯利·布比科伊（Ainsley Bubicoe）。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿（Creed Bratton）的《Rubber Tree》。想要收听无广告版本的《办公室女士》，请访问StitcherPremium.com。在Stitcher Premium上享受一个月的免费试用，请使用优惠码：OFFICE。本集目前还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可留下评论。